figaro lie gillet
18h50 précisément nous sommes le jeudi 7
avril j moins 3 avant le premier tour de
la présidentielle dernière ligne droite
dernier meeting nous allons les suivre
ensemble avec notamment marine le pen
qui doit s'exprimer dans un instant on
va voir cette image avec louis aliot
déjà qu'ils s'expriment depuis perpignan
louis aliot le maire de perpignan mer et
rennes ii perpignan et puis un peu plus
tard c'est valérie pécresse à lyon eric
zemmour à paris qui tenteront de
galvaniser une dernière fois leurs
militants avec moi erwan lestrohan
bonjour et roanne bonjour directeur
conseil à instituts de sondage oddo que
ça merci d'être avec moi vous pouvez
évidemment nous poser toutes vos
questions sur les différents chat sur
youtube sur le figaro sur sur facebook
je vous entends la première question
d'abord je précise quand même que les
favoris tous les favoris ne s'exprime
pas un emmanuel macron ne tient pas de
meeting cette semaine jean luc mélenchon
a tenu son dernier meeting avec
hologrammes c'était c'était mardi soir
ewan sprint final d'un point de vue
général qu'est ce qui se joue dans ses
derniers instants dans ses derniers
meetings alors ce qui se joue je dirais
qu'en fait on l'a dans notre sondage du
jour pour le figaro et backbone
consulting grosso modo sur dix électeurs
qui sont certains d'aller voter dimanche
il y en a trois sur dix qui sont pas
encore sûrs de leur choix soit parce que
ils ont choisi un candidat mais ils
peuvent encore changer soit parce qu'ils
ont même pas choisi le candidat pour
lequel ils votent rénale trois électeurs
sur dix qui sont sûrs d'y aller mais qui
sont encore suspendus et puis l'enjeu
des meetings il est double il est de
convaincre ses électeurs d'aller voter
mais aussi de pouvoir faire basculer
certains hésitent en moi d'abord se
concentrait sur sur marine le pen
puisque c'est elle qui ouvre le bal ce
soir on voit son clip de campagne dans
son meeting elle devra arriver d'un
instant à l'autre
elle a tout à perdre elle est en
deuxième position dans à peu près tous
les sondages
progresse elle se rapproche des manuels
macron c'est presque risqué pour elle
ses derniers instants ce serait erroné
de dire qu'elle n'a rien à perdre mais
elle est donc vraiment en position de
force qu'on voit dans notre sondage du
jour avec loeb sur les intentions de
vote c'est 24% des intentions de vote
pour marine le pen en deuxième position
en troisième position jean luc mélenchon
est quand même relégué loin derrière les
huit points derrière à 16 pour cent il
ya un écart très important qui semble
lui assurer une qualification pour le
second tour le point important
aujourd'hui ça va être surtout de
crédibiliser son projet est de faire une
dyna une preuve de sa dynamique et de la
force de ses soutiens et de diffuser des
images de meetings qui montre qu'elle
est soutenue par son public alors est ce
que ce soit le elle se projette déjà sur
le second tour en disant l'objectif
c'est de battre emmanuel macron ma
qualification est déjà sûre et où est-ce
qu'elle doit quand même faire attention
à jean luc mélenchon elle doit aussi
peut-être taper un peu sur les autres
candidats de droite quelle va être sa
stratégie on sait qu'elle a une campagne
très apaisé depuis le début un
absolument par contre sur cette question
du premier tour ce qui est évident c'est
que marine le pen ne peut pas l'enjamber
parce que pour transformer les
intentions de vote de son électorat en
participation réelle ya quand même un
travail on sait que c'est un hélico
alors on va arriver à un règlement qui
est plus abstentionniste dont il ya
quand même un vrai enjeu d'amener déjà
son électorat aux urnes pour le premier
tour on la voit grimper dans les
sondages est-ce qu'elle pourrait
dépasser emmanuel macron dimanche soir
être en tête de ce premier tour donc
pour l'instant c'est assez difficile
d'évaluer la dynamique à la baisse des
manuels macron et c'est là la hausse de
marine le pen mais ce qu'on voit c'est a
tendance à progresser et à progresser au
delà du cercle qui lui est acquis elle
gagne des points notamment chez les
français les plus âgés chez les cadres
chez les électeurs de françois fillon en
2010 est donc elle élargit sa base
électorale de là à savoir si elle
rattrapera celle d'emmanuel macron ça
reste encore une inconnue marine le pen
qui tient donc son dernier grand meeting
ce soir c'est à perpignan dans une ville
acquise à sa cause qui est aux mains du
arena louis l en est le maire marine le
pen qui s'expriment qui devrait
s'exprimer pendant environ une heure et
puis on se retrouve tout à l'heure pour
suivre les autres meeting de valérie
pécresse et d'eric zemmour
[Applaudissements]
je vous adresse
le plus sincère des saluts et à travers
veut un salut respectueux à tous les
français ceux des moeurs du pays comme
ceux de l'intérieur ceux de métropole
comme ceux d'outre-mer ceux de france
comme ceux de l'étranger ceux des
continents comme ceux des îles
c'est à vous tous
français de toutes origines de toutes
générations de toutes convictions de
toutes religions et de toutes régions à
vous tous français si chère à mon coeur
tous que vous soyez que je lance un
appel
je vais vous dire
que d'autres pays notre beau pays notre
cher pays a besoin de vous
[Applaudissements]
le soir
ce soit mes amis que nous allons
collectivement faire dimanche prochain
et dimanche 24
déterminera le sort du pays et donc
votre sort pour les années qui arrivent
et peut-être même les décennies qui
suivent
le message d'amour et de fraternité qui
est le nôtre
l'aspiration à la liberté qu'il sous
tend ce dessein de faire vivre un grand
projet collectif fédérateur nous devons
le porter jusqu'à la dernière minute de
cette campagne du premier tour jusqu'à
vendredi minuit
[Applaudissements]
je sais la flamme de la patrie qui brûle
dans votre coeur et que je vois briller
dans vos yeux
elle traduit cet indomptable énergie
dont notre peuple est capable lorsque la
situation l'exigé lorsque le sursaut
l'imposent pour perpétuer cet acte
d'amour et de passion qu'est la france
un même si parfois
si parfois les français n'ont pas
totalement conscience
ce 10 avril le pays un premier rendez
vous avec l'histoire un premier rendez
vous pour poser le débat fondamental qui
émergent dans tous les pays du monde
le débat entre nationaux et mondialiste
entre localiste et bio baliste entre
partisans de la protection est adepte de
la dérégulation
et comme il est légitime en démocratie
c'est tout peuple à vous amis citoyens
d'arbitrer cette grande question seuil
de ce troisième millénaire khroubi à
vous de décider du chemin que prendra la
france à vous de décider si la france
continue sa route
l'alternative est simple
ce sera soit la dilution dans un grand
magma mondialistes via une union
européenne qui en est le prélude
soit l'affirmation de la nation la
nation française tome espace protecteur
pour les nôtres
c'est devant soir il ne peut pas se
faire sans vous
l'histoire ne peut s'écrire sans vous
surtout si vous avez la france au coeur
si vous partagez avec nous l'amour de
notre peuple et la passion de l'avenir
depuis 40 ans nous français nous avons
vu avec tristesse le pays s'abîmer sa
puissance altéré son rayonnement faiblir
son économie sombre et sa confiance
s'évanouir
merci aux artistes d'être là
nous avons vu des quartiers entiers des
villes même échappé à toute autorité
républicaine
entrée en sécession sous le joug des
mafias de l'obscurantisme
nous avons vu que s'ils appliquent
parfois une autre voie que celle des
français
depuis cinq ans ce processus s'est
accéléré s'est aggravée si nous n'y
prenons garde la france verra son nom
effacées des livres d'histoire elle
deviendra un pays qu'il n'agit plus mais
obéit qui ne choisit plus mais subit
[Applaudissements]
à ceux qui croient
que la politique ne les concerne pas ne
les concerne plus je veux dire qu'il n'y
ait pas il n'a pu n'y a pas de situation
sans cause
si la question du pouvoir d'achat vous
être un aujourd'hui c'est parce que les
politiques passées vous ont appauvri ou
effondrés les comptes publics et ont
même endetté nos enfants pour longtemps
si emmanuel macron avait enrichi le pays
pardon
mais je ne parlerais pas de pouvoir
d'achat
si à la pompe vous vous sentez plus est
par le prix d'un plein c'est parce que
des décisions notamment fiscales on
prescrit de vous faire payer l'essence
au prix fort si vous redoutez la facture
de fuel de gaz ou d'électricité
quand vous ouvrez votre boîte aux
lettres c'est parce que en amont des
décisions de fermetures de centrales
nucléaires
l'absurde art image de notre électricité
sur les prix européens où les
subventions ruineuse à l'escroquerie que
sont les éoliennes l'on décidé pour vous
mêmes vous le voyez contre vous
mes amis pour changer de politique il
faut changer les politiques
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourquoi
avec solennité
avec insistance
une très bienveillante insistance je
vous conjure d'aller voter
[Musique]
aucun résultat net acquis tant que vous
n'avez pas voté à ceux qui ont pu rompre
avec le réflexe civique par colère par
dégoût par désillusion par fatigue je le
redis je vous comprends mais la re
devenez citoyens à la présidentielle on
ne s'abstient pas reprenez le contrôle
et puis en plus la météo devrait être
clémente
le temps idéal vont se rendre aux
bureaux de vote
ne soyez pas amnésiques mes chers
compatriotes
n'oubliez pas ce que vous avez vécu
les gilet jaune les retraités appauvrit
les ouvrières humilié les jeunes à qui
on a pris deux ans de liberté de manière
pas toujours justifiées
les familles qu'on a abandonné ces
territoires que l'on a oublié ces
français dont on disait qu'il n'était
rien ou qu'ils étaient non essentiels
rappelez-vous les mensonges les affaires
l'infantilisation du peuple souvenez
vous cette fameuse phrase du président
sortant lors de la sphère benalla qu'il
vienne me chercher
bien
c'est lé moment
puisque le calendrier institutionnel
nous y invite
le vote c'est mettre un bulletin dans
une enveloppe une enveloppe dans une
urne le 10 avril ce geste si simple et
pourtant si puissant il aura ce jour-là
une résonance particulière
il matérialisera la juste sanction que
mérite ce qui nous ont si mal gouvernés
à commencer par le président sortant
emmanuel macron
c'est pourquoi je vous le dis et le
redis mes amis je suis sûr que dans
cette salle vous en est persuadé on ne
s'abstient pas surtout quand on est
patriote surtout si on a conscience que
le pays a besoin d'un sursaut
[Applaudissements]
surtout si on a conscience qu'un
quinquennat de plus d' emmanuel macron
nous entraînera vers des points de non
retour vers un quinquennat sans frein ni
limite vers un quinquennat de
déconstruction nationale et de
désolation sociale
le temps est venu
le temps est venu pour le pays de
relever la tête de prendre ses décisions
qui comptera iront le court funeste des
événements qu un fatalisme ambiant
voudrait laisser se dérouler le temps
est venu pour le peuple de se lever le
temps est venu de rompre avec les forces
qui attirent notre pays vers le fond
pour qu'il retrouve très vite sa
stabilité sa joie de vivre sa place dans
l'histoire
jamais
[Applaudissements]
jamais mes amis la perspective d'un vrai
changement n'a été si proche
mais cela dépend de vous
n'oubliez jamais et répétés autour de
vous si le peuple vote le peuple gagne
[Applaudissements]
à
et puisque nous parlons de vote le 29
avril 1945 qui a presque 77 ans jour
pour jour les françaises votaient pour
la première fois de l'histoire
ah c'est vrai que beaucoup d'eau est
passée sous les ponts mais quelque chose
n'a pas changé
jamais dans l'histoire de la république
une femme n'a occupé les fonctions de
chef de l'état
[Applaudissements]
comme si une femme n'en était pas
capable
personne en tout cas de sérieux n'en
doute plus pourtant cette situation est
d'autant plus absurde que notre pays est
prêt et ce serait je crois un signe de
maturité démocratique
à l'image de tous les grands pays
européens
une femme à l'elysée voilà déjà un
changement
[Applaudissements]
un premier bien sûr et un vrai
changement dans cette élection
présidentielle
[Applaudissements]
sur la capacité d' autorité de décision
et de représentativité je suis persuadé
que les femmes n'ont rien à envier aux
hommes et messieurs tout en
reconnaissant vous immense et
indéniables qualités
peut-être les femmes sont elles plus
sensibles aux valeurs de protection plus
attachés au concret
c'est-à-dire au quotidien est plus
prudente lorsqu'il s'agit de leurs
enfants
moi je crois aux vertus d'une société
apaisée et d'un pays porteur de paix
et puis il ya des sujets qui sont
spécifiques aux femmes la santé féminine
avec les déserts gynécologique
l'endométriose ou le manque de sages
femmes
les problèmes de liberté dans l'espace
public avec le harcèlement de rue des
injonctions discours anti quand ce n'est
pas les mariages forcés sur notre
territoire les crimes d'honneur ou même
l'excision
à
des problèmes de carrière avec l'égalité
salariale et la conciliation de la vie
de famille et de la vie professionnelle
ses préoccupations essentielles pour
nous comme pour nos filles ces
préoccupations d'harmonie des rapports
hommes-femmes partagé aussi par les
hommes sont vous vous en doutez les
miennes croyez dans ma détermination à y
apporter des solutions et des solutions
rapides
dans
dans le monde tourmenté qui est le nôtre
la france possède un atout que beaucoup
nous envient en étant un état organisé
et structuré qui constituent les murs
porteurs de la maison france et un corps
de fonctionnaires dévoués au bien commun
des serviteurs de l'état qui assure en
toute circonstance la permanence des
services publics et la protection des
citoyens ce sont deux policiers ce sont
nos magistrats ce sont nous soignons et
bien je n'hésite pas à le dire comme
chef d'état emmanuel macron a failli
à
force est de constater en effet qu'en
cinq ans les fonctionnaires ceux de la
fonction publique d'état militaire
enseignants policiers hospitalière ou
territoriales ont été malmenés cela a
touché toutes les administrations
sans épargner la haute administration
les préfets les diplomates les
directeurs d'administration les
officiers généraux dont certains voire
purement et simplement leur statut
disparaître pour bien trouver de la
place pour les copains il manque des
milliers de magistrats
il manque des milliers de magistrats et
de greffiers
les enseignants sont notoirement sous
payés par rapport à la moyenne
européenne et les personnels
hospitaliers sont épuisés par les
rythmes qui leur sont imposées
[Applaudissements]
cette situation n'est pas digne de la
france de son rang du fonctionnement
normal de ces institutions
le scandale mckinsey
le scandale de ses cabinets étrangers
payés à prix d'or pour faire le même
travail que les agents de l'état est
venu mettre en lumière ces pratiques
d'inspiration ultra libérale
[Applaudissements]
concrètement elle constitue
indéniablement la marque d'un mépris
d'abord inadmissible et peut-être d'une
défiance humiliante pour les millions de
fonctionnaires français ça revient à
dire qu'ils sont incapables de faire le
travail que donc on va demander à
d'autres que l'on paye encore une fois
une somme folle de le faire à leur place
à tous les fonctionnaires de france je
veux exprimer ma confiance votre
confiance et leur dire le pays a besoin
de vous
[Applaudissements]
alors
à
[Applaudissements]
ciot ne se l'expliqu ait pas sur les
autres aspects du dossier mckinsey pas
ce cas là je préfère un meeting entier
des fraudes fiscales présumées les
possibles conflits d'intérêts les
manquements à la confidentialité puisque
la justice est saisie
mais chacun aura quand même compris que
ces pratiques constituent les prémices
inquiétante d'une privatisation des
fonctions publiques et même une
privatisation de la décision publique
vous voyez dans la conception des
manuels dacron tout est fait pour isoler
le citoyen
tout est fait pour le laisser sans
protection
individuelle ou collective
celle de l'état j'appuierai mon action
sur l'état l état que j'entends
restaurée dans ses moyens son autorité
son organisation son management
[Applaudissements]
mais mes chers amis c'est d'ailleurs
avec ce souci de remettre l'état à sa
place à sa juste place que j'ai conçu
mon projet notre projet n'est pas un
catalogue de mesures il n'est pas
seulement la réponse à des questions de
circonstances mais plus largement
beaucoup plus largement une vision pour
la france une vision à court à moyen et
à long terme notre projet ne vise pas
seulement à cinq ans mais à 10 ans 15
ans 20 ans même 50 ans pour ce qui
concerne par exemple les choix
énergétiques
industriels ou les choix de mots
graphique c'est un projet équilibré et
réaliste
complet et sérieux
solide et chiffré il a été préparé
depuis 2010 est avec le coeur et la
raison avec des certitudes et parfois
des doutes avec la fraîcheur de l'idéal
de la france et l'intransigeance des
réalités il a été réfléchie et mis au
point avec les spécialistes de toutes
les questions aux fonctionnaires homme
d'entreprise juriste conseiller d'état
constitutionnalise techniciens
militaires policiers médecins ingénieurs
professions libérales il a été confronté
à l' échange auprès de dizaines de
milliers de français que j'ai eu
l'honneur de rencontrer durant ces cinq
ans des professionnels des élus mais
aussi des hommes et des femmes de
terrain des personnes issues des
associations des rencontres de la rue
toujours si éclairante si pertinente si
enrichissante
ce projet assume pleinement son
aspiration nationale l'arrimage
indispensable à l'idée de nation cette
communauté naturelle qui fait de chaque
français un frère un héritier un
légataire
politiquement ce projet dont je suis
fier s'est donné comme centre de gravité
l'intérêt de la france et des français
avec moi il n'y aura aucune surprise
avec moi durant tout le quinquennat les
décisions publiques seront dictées par
un seul critère à quel est l'intérêt de
la france quel est l'intérêt des
français
[Applaudissements]
vous avez remarqué emmanuel macron passe
à bien parler des crises
la dcri ce qu'on a vécu les crises qu'on
a subi les crises qu'on a dû gérer
les crises dont emmanuel macron nous
parle en boucle comme le boxeur sonné
qui ressassent le moment de l'uppercut
qui l'a envoyé au tapis les crises
qu'elles soient sanitaires ou
énergétiques social migratoires sont en
réalité venu mettre en lumière les
fautes de nos dirigeants depuis tant
d'années ces dirigeants politiquement
interchangeables ont par idéologie ou
faiblesse sacrifié la souveraineté
industrielle et l'indépendance
énergétique
l'hôpital et la recherche médicale nos
territoires et nos fleurons industriels
ils ont laissé la majorité du territoire
français se désertifier en concentrant
tout dans les métropoles régionales
toutes les activités et vous le savez
très bien et ce qui vous ressentez cette
injustice à voir les universités les
centres de recherche les grandes
entreprises être systématiquement
attiré par montpellier ou par toulouse
ils ont oublié le rôle de l'état
stratège
et concédé le pouvoir au commissaire tri
de bruxelles ou au prohibitifs
conseillers de cabinets américains
tout le monde se pose est ce constat
objectif et louis vous l'a rappelé tout
à l'heure tous ceux qui ont été au
pouvoir ils ont tous échoué
à
tous les français je pose la question
et si on essayait autre chose
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
une autre voie une nouvelle énergie une
impulsion différente
avec moi le règne du laissez faire
laissez aller laisser passer c'est fini
[Applaudissements]
le gouvernement qui joue contre
l'intérêt des français c'est fini
l'elysée qui bradent les joyaux
nationaux s'est uni
la tête de l'état qui joue contre la
nation c'est fini
notre projet est national mais il est
aussi populaire en ce qu'il vise à
redonner la parole au peuple ce peuple
souverain que la casse a ignorés
méprisés et parfois matraque et
nous allons remettre le peuple au centre
du jeu politique et sa volonté au coeur
de la décision publique finis les bains
kinsey qui décide pour vous à vos frères
et à vos dépens
mais est finie aussi ce pouvoir qui vous
échappent qui s'évapore à bruxelles à
berlin ou ailleurs qui produit des
normes mais peu d'ordre qui coûte si
cher et rapporte si peu ce pouvoir
confluent du en même temps si loin et
pourtant si oppressant si incompétent et
pourtant si arrogant
enfin notre projet et social j'ose le
dire et je l'assumé en ce qu'il prend
totalement en compte les questions du
quotidien au premier rang desquels votre
pouvoir d'achat votre qualité de vie le
travail l'école ou encore par exemple le
sort des personnes en situation de
handicap les familles monoparentales ou
les retraités aux pensions de misère
[Applaudissements]
à
ah ah
en clair mes amis notre projet est assis
que sur une seule ambition celle que
nous avons pour notre pays celle que
nous imaginons pour notre peuple cette
belle ambition que nous construisons
pour chacun d'entre vous et croyez moi
je
tiendrai promesses je ne laisserai pas
ruiner vos espoirs décevoir vos attentes
je ne laisserai pas la volonté du peuple
d'être papous et comme elle ne fut
rappelez vous après le référendum de
notre projet il repose sur trois piliers
la protection la projection la
transmission la protection qui s'adresse
aux français d'aujourd'hui la projection
qui prépare la france de demain la
transmission qui assure ce lien
invisible mais si puissant entre les
parents et les enfants entre les
générations entre les français à travers
les âges
la protection tout d'abord pour un état
ce n'est pas une option mais une
obligation
elle est même sa raison d'être notre
protection extérieure militaire et
diplomatique sera évidemment restaurer
renforcer notre défense sera nationale
ça a l'air évident mais ça ne l'est plus
figurez vous elle sera appuyée sur la
dissuasion nucléaire détenus en propre
par la décision politique française est
uniquement française
la défense de la nation
renouera avec un robuste esprit de
défense veillera à la disponibilité et à
l'opérabilité des unités et à
l'amélioration de la condition militaire
notre armée sera restaurée dans ses
moyens
nous dégagerons 55 milliards pour elle à
l'horizon 2027 de même que le
renseignement et la présence terrestres
navales et aériennes
outre mer
[Applaudissements]
à l'intérieur maintenant à l'intérieur
nous partirons d'un principe simple
immuable non négociable et profondément
démocratique les français sont maîtres
chez eux
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis
[Musique]
je rendrai leur pays aux français
c'est aux français qu'il revient de dire
qu'ils entrent et qui doit quitter le
pays ce sera ni les juridictions
internationales ni les associations
immigrationnistes
ni d'ailleurs ceux qui viennent comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui qui décideront
qui vient outils s'installe dans notre
pays
ce sera aux français de décider qui est
digne de devenir français et d'avoir le
privilège
d'entrer dans la communauté nationale
être français n'est pas une situation
administrative
c'est un honneur
[Musique]
dès mon élection
nous ferons voter un projet de loi qui
en main sur l'immigration qui sera
proposé au débat et au vote il résoudre
à toutes les questions qui se posent
depuis 40 ans et que personne je dis
bien personne n'a voulu traiter ni même
seul non discutée
là aussi les principes seront connues
par tous un étranger qui vient en france
devra subvenir à ses besoins la
communauté nationale ne pourra pas le
prendre en charge
les demandes d'asile seront
obligatoirement effectuer et étudier à
l'extérieur de france
un étranger en situation irrégulière ne
sera jamais régularisables
on
ne peut pas ni dans ce domaine mes chers
amis ni dans d'autres mettre le peuple
français devant le fait accompli
ces gens qui sont en situation
irrégulière devront repartir chez eux
faire une demande
attendre qu'elle soit acceptée et
éventuellement pour pouvoir rejoindre le
territoire national
et de la manière la plus simple qui soit
deviendront français se et seulement ce
qu'ils méritent dans le devenir
[Applaudissements]
en matière de sécurité et de
tranquillité publique eh bien nous nous
inspirons du même principe c'est aux
français de dire quelle loi s'applique
chez eux ce ne sera ni la loi des caïds
ni celle des islamistes ni 7 et
pénalités financières mais la loi des
français
les moyens humains et matériels de tous
les acteurs de la chaîne pénale
police-justice pénitentiaires seront
renforcées dix mille policiers et
gendarmes supplémentaires sur le terrain
un maillage avec des police municipale
armée dans chaque commune depuis dix
mille habitants
[Musique]
le doublement à terme du nombre de
magistrats
25000 places de prison en plus et un
centre éducatif fermé par département
des procédures simplifiées des
coopérations internationales afin que
les étrangers purgent leur peine dans
leur pays d'origine
nous avons pardon mais nous avons assez
des nôtres pour ne pas nous encombrer
des délinquants étrangers qui n'ont
aucune raison de rester sur notre
territoire après avoir violé nos lois et
en premier lieu celle de l'hospitalité
[Applaudissements]
en revanche mon cher ami
à
[Applaudissements]
en revanche mes amis et vous en
connaissez tous
les étrangers qui sont présents parfois
depuis de nombreuses années sur notre
sol et respectent nos lois nos valeurs
notre culture nantes je le redis aucune
crainte à avoir
ils pourront même continuer à vivre dans
un pays plus sûr plus prospère plus
[Applaudissements]
ma politique pénale se résumera à un
triptyque simple
certitudes et poursuit certitude des
peines certitude de leur exécution
la justice civile dont on ne parle
jamais mais qui est importante pour des
millions de français les questions
d'impayés de loyers ou de divorce par
exemple sera rendue accessible rapide
c'est à dire en divisant les délais par
deux pour favoriser la sécurité
juridique de tous et pour tous le
sentiment de vivre dans un état de droit
parce que mon projet vise aussi à rendre
leur argent aux français nous nous
attaquerons
en fraude
nous nous attaquerons à toutes les
fraudes ah ben oui ces cartes vitale qui
circulent dans le monde avec de faux
assuré
de vrais prestation
cesit ces retraités étrangers de 120 ans
mais aussi les fraudes à l'importation
ou à l'étiquetage qui nuit ce temps à
nos producteurs et je n'oublie ni la
fraude fiscale ni les ententes qui
enrichissent quelques-uns et
appauvrissent tous les autres
la protection
la protection c'est aussi la santé dont
nous resterons les moyens les ehpad que
nous eûmes and is wrong le système
entier que nous revitaliseront ans le
des bureaucrates izon
la protection enfin c'est une grande
politique sociale en faveur du pouvoir
d'achat de tous mais aussi en faveur des
plus vulnérables
les blessés de la vie les personnes en
grande précarité les personnes en
situation de handicap les familles
fragilisées ou les étudiants paupérisée
je tiendrai la promesse d' emmanuel
macron qu'il n'a pas été capable de
tenir de se courir vraiment les
personnes en grande pauvreté
et d'offrir enfin une solution
d'hébergement à tous les sans abri
je ferai
se ferait de tous les français tu est
privilégiée dans leur propre pays
pour tous les français
j'établirai des nouveaux droits
spécifiquement liés à la nationalité
et notamment à ça les dérange il n'aime
pas ça nos adversaires
la priorité pour le logement et pour
l'emploi la priorité nationale
peut-être parce que c'est le bon sens
parce que c'est justice
[Applaudissements]
je mettrai d'ailleurs
je mettrai également en place des aides
spécifiques notamment en direction des
familles parce que les familles ont
énormément souffert dans les dix
dernières années pas seulement sous
emmanuel macron mais également sous
françois hollande où l'ensemble des
aides dont elle pouvait bénéficier ont
été baissés avec une conséquence directe
et mes chers amis sur les taux de
natalité c'est à dire les enfants qui
n'ont pas à cause de cela à cause des
situations de précarité un vu le jour
dans notre pays
protection disait ge mais aussi
projections nous remplacions la france
dans le concert des nations
favoriseront ce merveilleux moyen des
changes qu'à la francophonie dont on
n'entend plus jamais parler et puis nous
allons réformer l'union européenne pour
la remplacer par une alliance européenne
des nations avec des alliés qui en
europe n'attendent que cela
ce sera une coopération européenne
fondée sur le droit des peuples le
respect des états et la souveraineté des
nations
le pays tout entier se tournera vers ses
grands océans qui renferme l'or bleu la
richesse de demain notamment s'appuyant
sur notre territoire ultramarin
totalement délaissé depuis 20 ans
permettez-moi en votre nom d' adresser
un salut fraternel à nos compatriotes
d'outre-mer qui nous suivent et qui nous
soutiennent
alors oui notre france fidèle à sa
vocation s'investira dans la découverte
du continent bleus insuffisamment connue
et exploitera avec raison bien sûr ses
ressources pour en faire bénéficier ses
enfants nous engagerons une grande
politique énergétique de
réindustrialisation de relance des
filières productives d'avenir notamment
par le biais d'un fonds souverain
puissant doté de 100 milliards par an
abondée par l'épargné des français nous
allons rendre les français premier
actionnaire de la maison france
nous changerons meilleur ami nous
changerons le modèle économique non que
nous voulions sortir de l'économie de
marché bien sûr nous ne sommes pas
communiste mais nous voulons renouer
avec un modèle économique vertueux et
créateur d'emplois et de richesse pour
le pays donc pour vos emplois et votre
pouvoir d'achat ce nouveau modèle
s'appuiera sur nos petites les moyennes
entreprises sur le localisme sur le
patriotisme économique et sur
l'indépendance
indépendance énergétique industriel
scientifique médical agricoles et
alimentaires
à
ce parce que je sais et vous savez
d'ailleurs que nos tpe pme sont érodées
emplois de demain des innovations de
demain mais aussi les leviers du
rééquilibrage territorial que j'appelle
d'ailleurs de mes voeux que j'en ferai
une priorité la baisse des impôts de
production qui jusqu'à présent n'a
quasiment bénéficier qu'aux grands
groupes de toute façon tous bénéficient
toujours aux grands groupes des très
petites entreprises les petites et
moyennes entreprises sont
systématiquement oublié et bien avec la
suppression que je mettrai en oeuvre
pure et simple de la cotisation foncière
des entreprises ce sont les tpe pme qui
bénéficieront en priorité de cet
allègement d'impôts
enfin mes amis
il y à la transmission
parce qu'il n'y a pas d' envie de créer
et de développer de bâtir il n'y a pas
possibilité de transmettre
emmanuel macron à encourager la
spéculation
j'encouragerais la transmission
la transmission c'est d'abord la famille
ces familles françaises que je veux
aider je voulais dire que je veux
inciter à s'agrandir notamment en
accordant une demi part fiscale den
deuxième enfant et en leur réservant les
allocations familiales
et parce qu'il est parfaitement normal
de pouvoir transmettre à ses enfants son
patrimoine est le fruit de son travail
nous allégerons drastiquement les impôts
sur les successions et nous exonérons la
succession de l'outil de travail
la famille ce ne sont pas que les
enfants la famille c'est aussi les
seniors dont je refuse l'appauvrissement
et on me le reproche vivement c'est
pourtant là un choix de société
tout comme le droit de vivre une
retraite en bonne santé avec une
retraite de 60 à 62 ans maximum en
fonction de l'un d'entrer dans la vie
professionnelle
plus on travaille jeune plus on
travaille dur plus on doit partir ton
c'est cela la justice sociale
[Applaudissements]
là
à
la retraite à 65 ans des manuels macron
est une injustice sociale terrible
c'est une injustice sociale en plus
d'être une hérésie économique qui
appauvrira évidemment parce que c'est le
but nos anciens et 2 espèrera nos jeunes
je rétablirai également j'y tiens parce
que j'avais été terriblement choqué par
sa suppression
je rétablirai la demi part des veufs et
des veuves
et ré indexerait
les pensions sur l'inflation j'ai
entendu j'ai entendu le président de la
république hier soir dire qu'il a les
indexer les retraites sur l'inflation
je rappelle tout de même
je rappelle tout de même que sur les
cinq dernières années quatre années
quatre années pendant lesquelles les
pensions n'ont pas été réintégrés
chaque année elles ont été rognés par
l'inflation chaque année les retraités
ont vu baisser leur pension alors même
que pour beaucoup d'entre elles est déjà
si basse et bien moi je mettrais en
place une mesure pour que passe une
pension ne soit inférieur à 1000 euros
la transmission c'est aussi l'école
l'école qui doit redevenir le creuset du
savoir et pour les français les plus
récents de l'assimilation je veux
garantir à tous les petits français
cette belle égalité des chances à
laquelle comme républicains nous sommes
si attachés
l'un des pivots d'ailleurs de notre
projet ce sont les jeunes ces jeunes de
france qui sont dans l'angle mort de la
politique publique au point que beaucoup
pensent à s'expatrier ils sont notre
énergie notre réservoir créatif et
surtout dans un monde qui va bien la
société de la connaissance et vers une
révolution technologique permanente ils
sont un atout extraordinaire
c'est pourquoi nous allons vous jeunes
de france vous inciter à rester au pays
en vous exonérant d'impôt sur le revenu
jusqu'à 30 ans
et en permettant aux jeunes
entrepreneurs de moins de 30 ans dès
qu'ils exonérés d'impôt sur les sociétés
mais vous savez notre politique en
faveur des retraites participent à cet
objectif vital d'augmenter la part
d'activité chez les jeunes nous voulons
les sortir du chômage ou de l'a6 tenant
pour les faire entrer de plain-pied dans
la vraie vie celle où l'on exploite son
potentiel celle où l'on prend confiance
en soi ou en donne le meilleur de soi
même où l'on s'épanouit et où l'on
compte hier le monde
je vous entends les jeunes vous avez
envie de conquérir le monde
[Applaudissements]
la transmission cet enfant la culture
c'est l'âme d'un peuple et je sais
combien ici à perpignan vous êtes
rattaché
la culture
c'est d'abord la défense de notre langue
notre si belle
notre si belle langue tellement malmené
depuis un certain nombre d'années jamais
défendu par ceux qui nous dirigent et
bien ne peut être défendrons de toutes
nos forces parce que cette langue
française nous l'aimons et parce que
lé camp nou elle doit être transmise
sans avoir été dénaturé sans avoir été
abîmée à côté de la défense du
patrimoine pour lequel vous le savez
nous allons créer un service national
volontaires dédié pour les jeunes nous
assurons la promotion de la création en
aidant les jeunes artistes dénué de
relation par un soutien au circuit
indépendant de création d'expositions ou
de diffusion alors voyez vous avez bien
compris notre projet est l'antithèse de
celui présenté par emmanuel macron
notre vision de la nation n'est pas
désincarnés elle est celle de la raison
et du coeur nous n'avons pas eu besoin
nous d'apprendre à aimer les français
notre amour pour eux habitent
naturellement nos coeurs guide chacun de
nos pas de nos gestes
et envahi tous les jours nos pensées à
ceux qui nous écoutent je le dis avec
sincérité et confiance nous sommes prêts
[Applaudissements]
ma candidature
à
ma candidature est une déclaration
d'amour à la france elle est un acte de
piété à l'égard de ceux qui nous ont
précédés pour le présent elle est un
acte de fraternité et pour l'avenir un
acte de confiance
notre projet se distingue des autres en
ce qu'il est fondé sur le principe
fraternelle de la nation il se distingue
en ce qu'il postule non le mépris ou la
défiance de classe de certains tenants
de la droite ou de la gauche mais
l'unité de tous les français cette unité
qui rend notre nation invincible l'unité
c'est le socle sur lequel s'appuie la
vision que nous avons de la france elle
est le mur porteur du projet que je
présente au français l'unité c'est
l'antidote
l'antidote aux multiples fracturation de
notre pays fracturation social
territorial identitaire qui nous font
aussi mal que nos dirigeants successifs
n'ont pas su dominer et que parfois même
ils ont aggravé
l'unité nationale à laquelle j'appelle
les français les français de droite de
gauche et d'ailleurs les français de
métropole d'outre-mer et du monde est à
l'heure des grandes turbulences
mondiales et des profonds de transition
la plus saine et efficace réponses aux
défis qui se dressent devant nous c'est
pourquoi je lance un appel à tous les
français à nous rejoindre et à
participer à cette grande oeuvre
nationale
[Applaudissements]
l'élection présidentielle je voulais dit
n'est pas une élection présidentielle
comme les autres
je crois que rarement une génération n'a
eu entre ses mains soit si cruciale le
soin du destin d'une nation millénaire
les procès d'aujourd'hui doivent en
avoir conscience
conscience de ce soit qui les engage
pour eux mêmes et pour les générations
qui suivront tout comme ils doivent
savoir que l'europe entière et le monde
nous regarde le monde a besoin d'une
france qui retrouve sa hauteur et son
autorité pour poursuivre son oeuvre de
peur
c'est là sa mission c'est là sa vocation
l'europe elle a besoin d'une france qui
défendent la liberté la souveraineté et
la diversité des nations qui la
composent
nous allons vivre mes amis le moment
fondateur d'une ère nouvelle
une aire d'émancipation et de liberté
retrouvée une ère où le peuple sera à
nouveau respecté dans sa dignité dans sa
volonté dans son intégrité une ère où
chacun pourra choisir sa vie dans le
cadre d'une société respectueuse et
apaiser une ère où chaque parent pourra
être rassurés et fier du pays qu'il
laisse à ses enfants
nerfs ou la france renouera avec sa
vocation à la puissance et à la grandeur
la tâche qui nous attend est immense
mais nous sommes prêts et les français
sont avec nous avec eux
tout est possible déjà république telle
avance
de marine le pen qui s'achève à
l'instant on a bien compris qui était la
cible erwan vous êtes toujours avec moi
on va essayer d'analyser elle a attaqué
emmanuel macron là très clairement
pendant presque une heure alors c'est
vrai que sa place très fortement le
curseur pour le second tour où
l'adversaire et emmanuel macron et on
montre que c'est contre ce candidat là
en particulier que sont dirigés les
critiques oui c'est la question qu'on se
posait à vendre avant de prendre
l'antenne de lancer ce ce meeting quel
choix les faire marine le pen est ce
qu'elle se concentre déjà sur le
deuxième tour elle a presque envie on le
sent de réinstaurer elle aussi ce duel
le pen macron presque mélenchon zemmour
pécresse on parle quasiment pas la danse
dans ce meeting alors disons que c'est
surtout une mobilisation de ses
électeurs de premier tour qu'on voit
dans ce meeting mais autour d'eux du
vote contre du vote sanction contre la
politique d' emmanuel macron c'est
quelque chose qui prend une part
importante dans son discours on n'a plus
la même marine le pen qui à quelques
années oui c'est vrai qu'on est sortis
du de vue des fameux 3 et insécurité
immigration islam du rassemblement
national vraiment positionné sur le
pouvoir d'achat sur la proximité mais
marine le pen à faire un pas de côté par
rapport à son logiciel habituel mais
aussi en touchant la proximité des
français elle parle des déserts médicaux
de la sécurité du quotidien en faisant
ce pas de côté elle montre aux français
qu'elle connaît leurs conditions de vie
leur quotidien et c'est vrai que c'est
ça la plaçant pendant l inverse des
manuels macron qu'on décrit comme un
président parfois déconnectées des
réalités du quotidien des français vous
pouvez évidemment réagir toujours sur
sur les différentes les différents
canaux sur youtube sur sur lefigaro.fr
on a on a déjà des réactions alors je
voulais vous lire erwan ce que me disait
zygo 32 sur youtube pas fan de marine le
pen mais quels changements par rapport à
2010 est elle n'aura pas ma voix mais je
la trouve nettement plus affirmée et
crédible porto-novo aussi lui c'est sûr
le figaro pas de son bord mais elle a
fait de sacrés progrès marine le pen
elle devient convaincante elle a
bénéficié aussi faut bien dire les
choses de la position d'eric zemmour sur
sa droite qui finalement a recentré
aussi son image à renforcer la
crédibilité perçu 2 de son projet mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le prend la
parole sur des sujets qui dépassent les
questions d'immigration et de sécurité
qui étaient les fondamentaux du front
national et s'est incarné dans le
changement de nom aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus le front national ça n'est plus
l'affrontement c'est le rassemblement
national simply qui a un parti qui vise
à rassembler au maximum jacob saint
louis qui nous demande sur youtube où
sont les autres meetings il arrive
marine valérie pécresse elle est à lyon
c'est une réunion publique à lyon avec
laurent wauquiez on vous montrera sa
dans un ancien puits eric zemmour lui il
est à paris au palais des sports un
meeting pour pour les jeunes voilà pour
pour ce qu on attend maintenant il ya
aussi beaucoup de critiques sur le sur
les sur les différents chat beaucoup
reprochent à marine le pen sa position
vis-à-vis de poutine dans le passé ça ça
peut peser peut-être pas au premier tour
plus au deuxième voilà c'est ça c'est en
fait c'est plutôt un écueil de second
tour pour marine le pen ce qu'on a vu
c'est que otan ça a détérioré l'image de
jean luc mélenchon celle d'eric zemmour
marine le pen ça va pas détériorer son
image parce qu'on peut faire l'hypothèse
que son électorat est moins sensible à
ces questions de géopolitique
internationale que les électorats d'eric
zemmour ou de jean-luc mélenchon
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas une difficulté
pour marine le pen al'approche du
premier tour pour autant à la proche du
second tour on peut penser que dans
l'entre-deux-tours ses ambiguïtés à
l'égard de poutine l'emprunt russe ces
choses là vont pouvoir être rappelés et
peuvent la décrédibiliser dans l'optique
de rassembler un peu plus largement que
son socle électoral de premier tour
mouton lucide sur youtube qui nous dit
leur programme est consacré à la
destruction des pauvres musulmans est ce
que c'est tout à fait vrai ça est-ce que
le programme de marine le pen il porte
encore beaucoup sur l'islam pas
forcément il existe quand même des
références en critique à l'égard de la
place de l'islam en france à l'égard de
l'immigration mais ça ça n'est plus dans
la vitrine qui a affiché aujourd'hui et
ça a été assez peu abordée dans le
meeting convient de voir vous ne parliez
des 3i tout à l'heure qu'est ce que
c'est les trois i will et royer c'est
insécurité immigration islam c'est vrai
que ce sont les éléments qui structurait
beaucoup le discours du front national
on voit qu'aujourd'hui que le logiciel a
changé est ce que ça montre c'est aussi
la victoire de marine le pen sur eric
zemmour dans ce combat nouveau à
l'extrême droite c'est la victoire du
discours peut être anti système sur le
discours anti immigration ça ne signifie
pas que marine le pen n'a pas de
postures hostile à l'immigration mais ça
signifie que englober ça dans un récit
anti élites et anti système fonctionne
beaucoup mieux que dans un récit
uniquement construit autour des logiques
anti l'immigration vous me parliez
justement de lentilles de lentilles
système sébastien hall qui nous dit sur
sur facebook je pense qu'il est temps de
laisser cette dame qu'il est temps de
laisser cette dame est la présidente
nous avons tout essayé sauf marine
peut-être ça aussi essayer autre chose
ce qu'on appelait en 2017 le dégagisme
ça marche encore ça ça marche encore
mais ça concerne les personnalités qui
sont nouvelle dans le paysage politique
marine le pen c'est quand même
l'héritière d'une famille politique de
longue date intégré dans le paysage
politique national donc on n'est pas sûr
du dga gym mais c'est vrai que c'est un
des grands arguments du rassemblement
national de dire que tous les autres ont
été essayées et pas eux et c'est vrai
que dans un contexte de défiance à
l'égard de la capacité des politiques à
avoir des résultats c'est un argument
qui peut faire mouche pour une partie
des électeurs on suit dans un instant le
discours la réunion publique de valérie
pécresse on peut déjà voir l'image
peut-être avec benjamin des liens en
régie depuis lyon c'est bruno retailleau
qui s'exprime pour l'instant on reste
encore un petit peu sur marine le pen
pour débriefer ce qu'on vient d'entendre
à à perpignan alors elle a tapé un peu
plus sur macron que sur les autres elle
parle de mckinsey elle parle de l'europe
et east avec ce clivage entre macron
européiste et marine le pen l'a
souverainiste elle dit que macron a
abandonné les fonctionnaires elle veut
un vraiment instaurer ce clivage elle
sent que c'est face à emmanuel macron
qu'elle aura à combattre au deuxième
tour rappelez-nous les sondages que vous
nous donnez tout à l'heure du jour chez
aux docks çà et là de l'avant sur jean
luc mélenchon maintenant absolument
c'est ça emmanuel macron est à 28 %
d'intentions de vote marine le pen à 24
% ce qui la place huit points devant
jean-luc mélenchon à 16 % ce qui
correspond à peu près à trois millions
d'électeurs dont que ça lui donne un
matelas quand même assez considérable
davance mais c'est vrai qu'elles se
projettent déjà dans un duel de second
tour face à emmanuel macron le remake du
2017 et cette ligne de franco populiste
vers versus d euros progressistes se
retrouve encore dans la fracture entre
les deux électorats alors évidemment ce
ne sont que des sondages je veux pas
mais votre travail et mais pour
l'instant marine le pen n'est pas encore
qualifié au second tour on verra ça
dimanche soir j aurais qui nous dit
effectivement ce sera le duel du
mondialisme contre le patriotisme au
sens noble du terme on a compris de quel
bord et tj drogue va sûrement voter
marine le pen c'est vraiment ça il ya un
clivage là il ya un clivage fort oui
c'est un clivage fort mais c'est aussi
une manière de parler de la france c'est
vrai que ce qui va opposer beaucoup ses
candidats et ça peut être tout l'enjeu
du débat de l'entre-deux tours c'est
quel récit on va donner aux français
quelle cap on va donner aux français
pour la france et les deux ont des
arguments parce que avec la guerre en
ukraine on a aussi vu pour emmanuel
macron que ça réactivait l'importance de
la construction européenne pour la
défense nationale et ce à deux ça a du
sens aussi pour les français donc rien
ne paraît acquis mais ce récit pour les
français et pour l'avenir de la nation
france va être un des enjeux aussi du
débat d'entre deux tours alors on a eu
aussi un instant un peu particulier l'un
beaucoup insisté marine le pen sur le
féminisme une femme peut enfin être
présidente bon ça d'accord c'est le
discours qu'on a souvent entendu avec
avec valérie pécresse notamment ces
derniers temps avec anne hidalgo aussi
mais elle a insisté sur les sur les
femmes elle a pris une presque une
dizaine de minutes quasiment c'est
nouveau ça aussi celle rassemblement
national mais ça rentre aussi dans la
sphère de ses soutiens électoraux de
plus en plus les soutiens électoraux de
marine le pen ce sont les français qui
pensent que la démocratie fonctionne mal
et qui sont les plus susceptibles d'être
frappés par les crises économiques on
retrouve les demandeurs d'emploi les
employés et les ouvriers les jeunes mais
aussi les femmes et marine le pen elle
quand elle parle de déserts médicaux de
sécurité du quotidien de petites
entreprises de la cité de précarité
vidéo d'origine écologique dans le
meeting elle parle finalement de ces
difficultés du quotidien elle se place
encore dans cette posture de protection
des des français qui est vraiment la
matrice de son discours
il ya 1 commentaire de charles martel
son parcours est très habile c'est de la
m démagogie puissance 10 est ce que ça
peut la desservir à terme on sait
qu'elle a changé sur de nombreux points
marine le pen ces derniers temps on
pense à l'europe la binationalité et
l'immigration la retraite qui était à la
base dans son programme pour rester à 60
ans et puis finalement à soixante deux
ans on comprend pas forcément
exactement où elle veut en venir mais ça
a pas l'air de la desservir elle
progresse dans les sondages voilà après
c'est vrai que le l'écueil pour elle ça
pu être et l'iceberg ça peut être le
chiffrage du projet et c'est vrai que la
crédibilité économique dans un pays pour
lequel le redressement des comptes
publics est quand même un enjeu majeur
la crédibilité économique de son
programme et notamment de sa réforme des
retraites va être une des questions qui
va permettre aussi de cautionner son
projet en vue du deuxième tour voilà ce
qu'on pouvait dire sur ce meeting de
marine le pen on attend maintenant
valérie pécresse elle est donc à lyon
région rhône-alpes chez laurent wauquiez
évidemment c'est le meeting delà de la
dernière chance à roanne alors c'est pas
forcément le meeting de l'intérieur mais
c'est un meeting qui a des enjeux
aujourd'hui on mesure 7% d'intentions de
vote pour valérie pécresse est très
basse et un point et demi le score déjà
très bas de françois-xavier bellamy aux
européennes de 2019 ça la place à un
niveau très bas et surtout en dessous
d'eric zemmour qui a 8 % d'intentions de
vote et tout l'enjeu c'est ça aussi
c'est de réussir dans l'optique de la
reconstruction de la droite post
présidentielle a figuré peut-être au
mieux et pas un niveau trop bas valérie
pécresse a manqué une semaine on le
rappelle de de campagne à cause du à
cause du coc vide elle veut occuper le
terrain c'est le moment c'est dernières
semaines elle veut y aller à fond elle a
répété ce qu'il n'est pas trop tard on
sait qu'elle a lancée notamment la
grande vadrouille avec 150 jeunes qui
sont partout en france pour pour essayer
de convaincre les derniers les derniers
militants les derniers électeurs
potentiellement elle peut y arriver on a
déjà vu des retournements de situation
ce ne sont que des sondages je le
rappelle mais elle est assez bas france
oui et c'est vrai que laissaient
d'ailleurs que quand vous dites ce ne
sont que des sondages vous avez tout à
fait raison parce que finalement les
sondages sur une photo à l'instant t
mais ça ne remplace pas évidemment de se
rendre aux urnes ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est que pour
crédibiliser son projet jusqu'au dernier
jour et amener ses électeurs vers les
urnes valérie pécresse va devoir prendre
la parole jusqu'au dernier moment ça
c'est un point très important et un
autre point qui est important c'est que
ces électeurs dont beaucoup sont partis
vers emmanuel macron au cours des
dernières semaines sont un peu moins
sûrs de leur choix ils sont que 70 % à
être sûrs de leur choix ce qui est
autour de 10 % de moins que les
électeurs des manuels maquereau ou que
les électeurs d'eric zemmour que les
électeurs de marine le pen aux canards
noirs un peu moins convaincus et du coup
elle va devoir renforcer leurs
convictions pour transformer leurs
bonnes intentions en participation
effective dans les urnes dimanche si
vous nous rejoignez on vient de suivre
le discours de marine le pen qui était à
perpignan on attend maintenant valérie
pécresse qui est à lyon eric zemmour un
peu plus tard qui lui est à paris d'un
discours sur les jeunes on parlera
d'eric zemmour campagne difficile donc
un on peut en parler de valérie pécresse
vous nous posez vos questions sur sur
les différents chat
qu'elle est la dynamique en ce moment
pour pour valérie pécresse est ce qu'on
craint une catastrophe à la socialiste
2017 ou à la régionale pour les l'air
2019 ou au contraire un espoir comme
lors des élections régionales ça s'est
bien passé pour l'instant la dynamique
est plutôt à la baisse et les signaux qu
on observe ne prêtent pas à l'optimisme
par exemple aujourd'hui valérie pécresse
ne recueille qu'un tiers du vote filion
en 2017 ça c'est un indicateur qui est
quand même passablement inquiétant elle
est concurrencée sur ce vote filles ont
très fortement par emmanuel macron mais
aussi par marine le pen mais aussi par
eric zemmour autre point inquiétant pour
valérie pécresse sait quel recul dans
les intentions de vote des segments
incontournable de soutien à l'ump puis
eau l air que sont les français âgés de
65 ans et plus et les cadres ces deux
populations qu'ils ont pourtant des
soutiens quasi inaliénable des
républicains le tracé a reculé dans
leurs intentions de vote pour valérie
pécresse a lui préféré emmanuel macron
donc les signaux prête pas à l'optimisme
maintenant il reste encore trois jours
pour se décider pour une partie des
électeurs suspendu on reste en direct
nous on discute encore un petit peu de
valérie pécresse mais on peut déjà voir
ces images qui nous arrive de lyon avec
avec plusieurs candidats envoient avec
plusieurs ténors pardon la seule
candidate elle est là
pécresse on a vu on a vu laurent
wauquiez on a vu bruno retailleau ici
monsieur hamad qui s'exprime voilà pour
ce dernier meeting cette dernière
réunion publique un pur pour valérie
pécresse est-ce que c'est pas aussi un
meeting pour remobiliser ses troupes à
un tout petit peu plus long terme il ya
les législatives qui arrive il ya une
crainte que ce parti des républicains
est close alors sur la question des
législatives c'est en plus une élection
qui peut être très favorable aux
républicains on a vu que les municipales
les régionales avaient été des séquences
favorable aux républicains qui sont bien
implantés localement et qui ont tout à
gagner au législatif qu'une petite
spécificité les législatives c'est que
pour qualifier pour le second tour il
faut avoir 12 5% des voix des électeurs
inscrits donc à un haut niveau de
participation de d'abstention ça
favorise les sortants et donc ça peut
être très bénéfique pour les
républicains il ya tout un enjeu
stratégique de garder une homogénéité et
une solidité du bloc législatif les
républicains et donc à garder des forces
vives dynamiser jusqu'à cette séquence
qui arriveront en modulant on parle des
meetings ce soir on suit les derniers
grands meetings j'ai une question pour
vous parce que valérie pécresse ce que
ces meetings ils sont pas finalement
dangereux pour l on connaît les
critiques qui lui sont tombées dessus
après son meeting du zénith en février
est ce qu'elle est en difficulté dans
ces moments là et est ce que elle le
paye dans les sondages ensuite alors
elle a pas nécessairement payer dans les
sondages mais c'est vrai que les
meetings c'est des accélérateurs soit en
positif soit en négatif qu'un meeting
réussi avec des gros mouvements de foule
une dynamique de la liesse donne un
accélérateur positif et qu'un meeting
ratés comme ça a été le cas pour valérie
pécresse peut être un accès leur
accélérateur négatif parce que en
quelque sorte ça décrédibilise le
candidat et nous en l'occurrence donc ça
on avait mesuré une baisse des
intentions de vote à l'égard de valérie
pécresse dans la foulée du meeting ça
n'est pas le seul signal qui détournent
les électeurs d'un candidat mais ça peut
y participer en effet que ce qui peut
détourner aussi les sympathisants à
l'ère du vote de valérie pécresse c'est
le nom ralliement où la nonne annonces
de soutien de nicolas sarkozy beaucoup
de monde sur le chat qui nous en parle
est-ce que ça elle le paye est ce que
les sympathisants et l'air
10 nicolas sarkozy n'a pas soutenu
valérie pécresse je ne soutiens pas je
ne voterai pas valérie pécresse c'est la
même chose que le meeting c'est vraiment
sur ces éléments de crédibilité et de
sentiments qui est renvoyée cela
participe à fragiliser la candidature de
valérie pécresse c'est à dire est ce que
ça donne le sentiment qu'on est dans le
bon bateau ou pas quand on est quand on
a des images d'un meeting avec d une
foule en liesse ça donne le sentiment
que c'est un bateau qui va de l'avant
qui est dans une dynamique quand il ya
des ralliements idem quand et des
ralliements on se dit tiens c'est le
candidat qui a le vent en poupe
aujourd'hui du coup ça donne le
sentiment d'un bateau qui n'a pas le
vent en poupe et c'est plutôt négatif
pour les candidats évidemment on voit
donc les images depuis lyon avec valérie
pécresse qui est attendu d'une minute à
l'autre il ya eric zemmour aussi qui va
qui va s'exprimer on va en parler on va
rester sur ces images de lyon et je
voulais parler quand même d'eric zemmour
parce que lui aussi il parle tout à
l'heure depuis depuis paris au palais
des sports c'est un meeting des jeunes
avec zemmour la carte jeune pour lui ce
soir ce qu'il a parlé aux jeunes dans
cette campagne eric zemmour oui puis
devrait montrer qu'il ya une génération
zemmour comme s'appellent son groupe de
soutien chez les jeunes aujourd'hui
c'est un peu compliqué pour aiguiser
moore chez les jeunes il a 7 %
uniquement dans notre dernier sondage
d'intention chez les 18 24 ans 7 %
seulement il parle beaucoup moins aux
jeunes que marine le pen par exemple qui
recueille des scores d'intentions de
vote élevées notamment auprès des 25 34
ans l'électorat de eric zemmour lui est
plus âgé pour qu'ils votent les jeunes
d'ailleurs dit moi ils votent plus
majoritairement pour emmanuel macron et
jean luc mélenchon d'accord qu'ils
devancent marine le pen qui arrive en
troisième position dans cette population
donc peut-être ce soir ce meeting des
jeunes avec zemmour on comprend
peut-être la subtilité de ceux de ce
dernier meeting il est sur une mauvaise
pente sondagière hexagonal oui plutôt ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que après être
monté jusqu'à 14% dans nos intentions de
vote au mois de février il accuse une
baisse depuis depuis deux mois qui lie à
un double mouvement il ya les positions
à l'égard de la russie la question des
réfugiés qui ont décrédibilisé sa
solidité et sa stature et il ya aussi le
regain de marine le pen dès lors que la
campagne c'est nationaliser qui a vu
revenir vers elle des électeurs qui
avait été tenté par eric zemmour on les
eaux qui dit ça sent la bonne grosse
gifle électorale pour le chantre du
grand remplacement des partis trop vite
avec des mots on l'a vu peut-être trop
beau au mois de novembre alors il est
parti trop vite et est parti à un moment
où le corps électoral était plus
resserré et ou qui lui donnait aussi la
période à la possibilité de s'exprimer
c'est plus difficile de s'exprimer quand
emmanuel macron et marine le pen sont
rentrés en campagne donc il est rentré
assez tôt ces thèmes ou fortement occupé
le débat médiatique aujourd'hui ce qu'on
voit c'est que y'a et d'une peut être un
essoufflement et peut-être le manque
aussi d'un complément c'est-à-dire qu'il
ya peut-être une attente de son
électorat que au delà de la question de
l'opposition et de l'hostilité à
l'immigration et l'islam ça soit
accompagnée de mesures économiques et
d'un récit global c'est peut-être cette
pierre là qui a manqué à l'édifice
d'eric zemmour ces images toujours qui
nous parviennent depuis lyon avec ce
meeting cette réunion publique cette
dernière réunion publique de valérie
pécresse on évoque le cas d'eric zemmour
qui lui s'exprimera un peu plus tard
depuis depuis paris
c'est difficile ses positions pro
poutine pour pour eric zemmour lui les
subit vous disiez tout à l'heure tu
marine pour l'instant elle n'avait pas
subi ça dans les sondages lui un
problème avec ça oui parce que il parle
un électorat qui est sensible à ces
questions là qui s'intéressent à
l'actualité politique qui s'intéressent
à la vie politique et qui se préoccupe
de l'actualité internationale ce qui
peut le sanctionner beaucoup plus
fortement parce que ça nuit à son image
médiatique que marine le pen qui ne vise
pas à cet électorat mais ça me dit rien
des élèves de l'école que rentrer que
rencontrera marine le pen dans
l'entre-deux tours où elle pourrait être
confrontée à ses positions passées à
l'égard de la russie nombreux sont les
candidats qui critiquent les sondages
qui vous critiquent vous êtes doxa je le
rappelle surtout ceux qui sur tous les
candidats qui sont en mauvaise posture
mais eric zemmour il tape
particulièrement fort vous êtes sondeurs
vous pensez que vous pouvez vous tromper
ya beaucoup de questions là dessus sur
nos différents chat en disant ouais
c'est les sondages c'est les sondages
démons peut encore gagner bon alors il
ya une pluralité d'instituts ça fait
nombreuses institut donc il ya une
récurrence des mesures de mesures qu'ils
ressemblent beaucoup donc on peut être
tenté de penser qu'on ne sait pas
tellement tromper mais le risque zéro
évidemment n'existe pas c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est ce que je
vous disais tant que les gens ne sont
pas allés voter de toute façon il n'y a
pas de rapport de force électoraux c'est
uniquement une photo qu'on fait
aujourd'hui est le point qui est
important et c'est vrai que c'est tout
l'enjeu pour les sondeurs c'est depuis
quelques années on a vu monter avec des
grandes séquences abstentionnistes les
municipales et les régionales et on a vu
monter une imprévisibilité électoral
plus forte et une plus grande difficulté
mais des français eux-mêmes à convertir
leur intention de voter en participation
effective dans les urnes et ça ça rend
les élections un peu moins prévisible
mais on adapte aussi nos outils pour
mieux rendre compte de cette
imprévisibilité électoral plus fort mais
c'est vrai que c'est un enjeu
aujourd'hui voilà je vous dirais que le
risque zéro n'existe pas que la
récurrence des crises parlerons des
régionales et rigueur c'est vrai que sur
les régionales les sondeurs se sont
plutôt tromper c'est plus compliqué de
mesurer les élections régionales que
l'élection présidentielle c'est une
élection qui à capri une perte de 15
points de participation entre l'édition
2015 et l'édition 2021 et quand le corps
électoral est restreint la mobilité des
électeurs pèse fortement sur les
rapports de force si vous enlevez 15 %
du corps électoral bon bah
nécessairement les rapports de force
sont pas les mêmes que ceux que vous
avez estimé dans votre sondage est que
la démobilisation a été très forte ça
c'est une chose à laquelle on ne
s'attendait pas c'est aussi la nouveauté
du coc vide et de la désaffection des
urnes mihocko vide à laquelle on
s'attendait pas on suit les derniers
grands meetings on rappelle qu emmanuel
macron n'aura donné qu'un seul grand
meeting c'était ce week end à nanterre
que jean luc mélenchon a donné son
dernier grand meeting c'était mardi lui
avec son fameux meeting hologrammes et
puis ce soir ce sont les candidats de la
droite parmi les favoris qui s'exprime
une dernière fois on a suivi tout à
l'heure marine le pen qui est à
perpignan on attend valérie pécresse et
images de lyon toujours en direct
valérie pécresse qui devrait avec ne
devrait pas tarder à arriver et puis
eric zemmour qui lui est au palais des
sports on suivra également dans quelques
dans quelques minutes est ce que on
parle beaucoup des abstentionnistes
l'abstention pour être immense jamais vu
dimanche on peut entendre est ce que ces
derniers meetings peuvent convaincre et
s'il ya des gens qui se décide à mme
martin 28% des français en 2017 qui
disait qu'il s'était décidée dans les
derniers jours et aujourd'hui en
appareils 29 % des gens qui n'ont pas
encore finalisé leur choix donc bien
entendu que ça peut mobiliser les
abstentionnistes sachant qu'on a une
abstention qui pourrait être encore
aujourd'hui on mesure dans notre dernier
sondage avec le figaro
27,4 % d'abstention probable c'est très
proche du 28,2 qui est le record de 2002
ça nous situe très largement au dessus
des 22 % de 2017 ma lancée voilà cette
dernière ligne droite qui va permettre
de mobiliser les 30 % d'électeurs qui
reste encore un peu suspendue et les
convaincre d'aller aux urnes et sacs
pour faire le trajet de chez eux
jusqu'où il ya énormément d'éléments de
mobilisation qui devront passer par la
sq il est vrai que bon nombre de
français ne savaient pas lundi qu'ont
voté dimanche est ce qu'on peut savoir
ça au delà de est ce que les gens vont
voter est ce qu'ils savent qu'on vote
est-ce qu'ils sont concernés j'imagine
que vous faites des sondages aussi là
dessus absolument alors ya dix jours il
ya un tiers des français qu'ils savaient
pas que le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle avait lieu le dimanche 10
avril là en début de semaine quand on a
interrogé les français il s'est quand
même neuf sur dix à savoir qu'il y avait
l'élection présidentielle ce dimanche
pour que c'est pas un déficit de
notoriété de l'élection maintenant toute
la question c'est de savoir si des gens
risquent de se détourner des urnes parce
qu'ils ont le sentiment que s'est jouée
d'avancé parce qu'ils ont le sentiment
que ça ne répond pas à leurs attentes ou
tout simplement parce qu'ils ne
s'intéressent pas à la politique mais ça
on le saura dimanche en constatant les
résultats des images qui nous arrive de
lyon avec ce dernier meeting de valérie
pécresse et laurent wauquiez qui va
assez michel barnier qui s'expriment
j'ai cru que c'était laurent wauquiez de
dos avec 7,7 chevelure blanche on voit
que tous les ténors se suivent là c'est
important de mobiliser de montrer qu'on
est tous rassemblés c'est une habitude
ça dans les dents les dernières
campagnes tous ensemble au dernier
moment jusqu'au bout alors certains
certains candidats et même certaines
candidates ont fait le choix
d'apparaître seul ou en effectif très
ramassée dans les meetings il ya
plusieurs options mais c'est vrai que
dans l'optique où on vise une formation
gouvernementale et à être dirigé le pays
c'est important de montrer qu'il existe
plusieurs poids lourds aux côtés du
candidat et que le projet de
gouvernement est quand même très
crédible je voulais parler un petit peu
des petits candidats on va faire un
petit tour les petits candidats beaucoup
beaucoup sont sont à gauche ces derniers
temps pensa à fabien roussel on pense à
yannick jadot qui tiennent d'ailleurs
des meetings bossi aussi ce soir on
pense à anne hidalgo est ce qu ils
peuvent permettre à jean luc mélenchon
lui de se surpasser et de rattraper
marine le pen emmanuel macron qui semble
devant lui dans les sondages est-ce
qu'il peut y avoir un détournement de ce
vote en disant allez le vote utile pour
jean luc mélenchon alors c'est sûr que
c'est les réserves de voix dont jean luc
mélenchon devra bénéficier s'il veut se
ici jusqu'à la faible qualification pour
le second tour ce qu'on observe
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs c'est que les
intentions de vote pour jean luc
mélenchon augmente très fortement dans
cette ce qu'on pourrait appeler cette
gauche modérée c augmente très fortement
chez les salariés du public chez les
français les plus âgés et même chez les
sympathisants ps et les chats chez les
sympathisants europe ecologie les verts
donc on voit bien que cette gauche
modérée commencent à se tourner vers
jean luc mélenchon maintenant toute la
question c'est rare si ses réserves
seront suffisantes pour lui permettre de
se hisser au deuxième tour et de
récupérer les points qui lui manquent
encore on rappelle que la campagne
s'arrête officiellement vendredi soir
c'est pour ça que les derniers meetings
se font ce soir pourquoi pas demain
parce que c'est vrai qu'après il reste
plus d'image à diffuser pour le samedi
samedi n'y aura aucune diffusion à
partir du vendredi soir minuit il est
interdit de diffuser des informations
sur les propositions des candidats des
messages des candidats tout comme nous
il nous est interdit de diffuser des
sondages sur les rapports de force
politiques c'est la loi électorale à
partir de vendredi minuit les français
sont laissés libres de leur choix et ne
reçoivent plus les messages sur les
propositions politiques n'hésitez pas à
nous poser toutes vos questions sur sur
les différents chat sur les différentes
vidéos sur youtube sur facebook sur
lefigaro.fr on essaie d'y répondre ici
la question des sondages également vous
avez le droit de faire des sondages
jusqu'à quand alors nous on a le droit
de faire des sondages tout le temps on
n'a pas le droit de les publier d'accord
à partir de demain soir à minuit mais on
a le droit de faire des sondages tout le
temps et rien n'interdit à certains
instituts à titre confidentiel de
réaliser des sondages même la journée du
samedi où la journée du dimanche ces
sondages est-ce qu'ils sont volatiles
dans les derniers instants ainsi qu'à
des gens qui y paniqués qui se disent au
dernier moment je change je vote pour
quelqu'un d'autre alors c'est vrai que
ça c'est des choses qui arrivent déjà
mais aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit c'est que
30% des électeurs n'ont toujours pas
fait leur choix même s'ils sont sûrs
d'aller voter dimanche par contre on
n'arrivera pas à 0 dimanche il ya des
gens qui iront voter dimanche tout en
n'étant pas sûrs de leur choix donc ça
reste quand même une part des lecteurs
suspendu qui est importante j'avais noté
mois dans les intentions de vote pour
les campagnes présidentielles que les
intentions de vote de milieu de semaine
était en général plus proche du résultat
définitif que les intentions de vote de
fin de semaine et c'est ce que vous
dites c'est que il est possible qu'ils
aient des électeurs qui dans la dernière
ligne droite se met à changer
complètement leur plan que ça bouleverse
un peu les rapports de force et puis qui
reviennent finalement à leur première
conviction en fin de semaine et devant
lui en donc on est dans une période dans
une dernière ligne droite où ça peut
encore bouger avec ses électeurs
suspendu qui peuvent se laisser tenter
soit par un autre candidat soit par
l'abstention soit par le vote blanc ou
nul donc vous êtes en train de me dire
que les derniers sondages les plus
proches théoriquement de ceux qui des
résultats de dimanche soir sans ceux qui
sont tombés hier et aujourd'hui alors
c'est possible ceci dit en 2017 on avait
un événement un peu tragique sur la fin
de la campagne c'était le xavier juge
les le policier qui avait été tué à s'en
servir sur les champs elysées il est
bien sûr c'était trois quatre jours
avant le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle là on a pas d'évènement
qui soit venu vraiment bousculé la
campagne donc on peut imaginer que les
rapports de force évoluent relativement
peu même si ses meetings ont de
l'importance parce qu'il faut encore une
fois conduire les électeurs vers les
urnes et rien de mieux pour ça que leur
montrer qu'il existe une dynamique
autour de la candidature on a suivi le
meeting ensemble de marine le pen qui
était à perpignan pour essayer de
galvaniser une dernière fois ses troupes
on suit dans un instant le meeting de
valérie pécresse à lyon qui est aux
côtés de laurent wauquiez envoyer si
michel barnier qui s'expriment suivre
aussi le meeting d'eric zemmour il est à
paris lui avec les jeunes on va revenir
sur valérie pécresse parce que c'est
elle qui devrait s'exprimer le plus
rapidement c'est une campagne difficile
qu'est ce qu'elle a manqué les français
que vous interviewez régulièrement
qu'est ce qui leur manque dans ce que
fait valérie pécresse depuis le début de
cette campagne évidemment ce ne sont que
des sondages mais pour l'instant elle
est mal placée alors quand un candidat
réalise comme ça une campagne sur
laquelle ne rencontre pas la demande
politique on peut se dire que c'est
peut-être aussi qu'il n'avait pas d'
espace politique finalement valérie
pécresse ce qu'a essayé de prendre la
parole à la fois sûre du conservatisme
culturel et en même temps sur du
libéralisme économique on voit que
finalement son espace politique sur le
conservatisme culturel a été pris par
eric zemmour qui finalement lui proposer
des choses beaucoup plus qu'y aller
beaucoup plus loin sur ces questions là
et son espace politique sur le
libéralisme économique finalement il a
été pris par emmanuel macron cas même
pioché quasiment dans ses propositions
finalement elle s'est retrouvée dénutri
et sur le plan des traits culturels et
sur le plan d'aidé très économique et du
coup c'est vrai qu'on peut comprendre
que le jeu de vases communicants et
était en sa défaveur ça a été difficile
d'imprimer une offre un peu spécifique
puis plus largement et à cette difficile
de cette difficulté pour les plus vieux
parti c'est de représenter quelque chose
aux yeux des électeurs de plus en plus
dans les enquêtes ce qu'on voit c'est
que europe écologie les verts la
république en marche la france insoumise
sont départis récents dont les français
savent bien ce qu'ils proposent mais
aujourd'hui l'offre politique du parti
socialiste l'offre politique des
républicains elle semble un peu datés et
le logiciel ne parle plus beaucoup aux
français donc à cette question aussi de
la singularité de l'offre les
républicains qui a été difficile à
trancher pendant la campagne dont elle
paye peut-être les pots cassés
aujourd'hui on voit tous les tous les
ténors qui sont assez à ce meeting de
valérie de valérie pécresse
ils sont tous réunis dans l'ain qui
manquent on en a déjà parlé c'est
nicolas sarkozy qui disait que les
républicains d'imprimer plus à ce qu'ils
ont perdu 7,27 à mme sarkozyste ses
peurs c'est un point qui était assez
important dans l'électorat sociologie de
l'électorat des républicains au moment
de l'élection de nicolas sarkozy en 2007
c'est qu'il avait réuni l'ensemble de la
droite mais aussi et ça faisait corps
avec le travailler plus pour gagner plus
les électeurs pauvre de la droite les
électeurs les plus modestes du duc en l
air et c'est vrai que ces électeurs là
ont déjà été perdus dans la base
électorale de françois fillon en 2017 et
on voit que c'est une grande partie des
électeurs qui sont dirigés vers marine
le pen est kiné qui ne sont plus du tout
tourner vers l'offre
les républicains auraient déjà cette
déperdition et puis aussi cette capacité
de nicolas sarkozy à faire corps
totalement avec les sympathisants les
républicains moi je crois que
d'analystes de la popularité de nicolas
sarkozy entre 2007 et 2012 je crois pas
qu'il soit descendu en dessous de 80 %
de bonnes opinions auprès des
sympathisants et l'air aujourd'hui
valérie pécresse il ya seulement la
moitié des sympathisants et l'eire qui
votent pour être qu'ils ont l'intention
de voter pour elle à la présidentielle
donc cela dit quand même l'écart entre
nicolas sarkozy et valérie pécresse mais
aussi sur cette capacité à fédérer
l'ensemble de l'électorat qui fait
défaut aussi aujourd'hui à la candidate
si je vois eldorado qui nous parle sur
sur youtube
il fait le rapprochement entre marine le
pen et eric des mots et dit qu'il faut
combiner ses voix est-ce que marine le
pen a une réserve de voix plus forte qu
emmanuel macron en vue du deuxième tour
grâce à eric zemmour en quelque sorte
alors ça de prime abord c'est ce qu'on
peut se dire ce que nous indique les
reports de voix aussi 1 80 % de
l'électorat d'eric zemmour se dirigerait
vers marine le pen maintenant on va voir
quand même dans l'entre-deux tours et le
au soir du deuxième tour si ça peut être
un mariage heureux est purement
arithmétique c'est à dire que la somme
des voix d'eric zemmour se dirige vers
marine le pen ou du moins 80% d'entre
elles et c'est aussi la dilution
zemmour isme dans le pénis nous c'est
aussi une question qui va se poser parce
qu'il va falloir que les candidats
s'entendent est ce que eric zemmour va
appeler personnellement à voter pour
marine open est ce qu'il va dire qu'ils
votent marine le pen est ce qu il
appelle à voter contre emmanuel macron
en en disant pas plus tous ces petits
éléments là aussi ça va donner des
informations sur la capacité de ce
mariage à se transformer en mariage
heureux en tout cas du côté des
électeurs ça a l'air plutôt à qui il va
falloir voir comment ça se passe au
niveau des candidats je vous rappelle
qu'on attend ensemble les prises de
parole les dernières prises de paroles
d'eric zemmour et de de valérie pécresse
on va dire simplement le premier qui
parle c'est le premier qu'on diffuse
alors on leur demande de se dépêcher
mais qu'il a dès qu'ils arriveront les
diffuser on les écoute évidemment et
valérie pécresse dont on voit les images
du meeting à lyon va se créer dans un
instant sur quoi elle a insisté ces
derniers jours et sur quoi on peut
l'attendre la dent dans les dernières
minutes je pense que là la vraie
singularité de ce que proposent les
républicains et la vraie force du projet
de valérie pécresse sur laquelle doit
insister et ça fait particulièrement
sens dans un contexte d'inquiétude des
français d'incertitude de crise
environnementale sanitaire économique
tout ce qui est crise internationale
aussi c'est cette capacité des
républicains à accéder aux
responsabilités à gérer un pays à gérer
un gouvernement et c'est quand même la
grande force cet exercice cette habitude
des responsabilités politiques chez les
républicains que valérie pécresse doit
mettre en avant c'est à dire qu'avec
valérie pécresse le pays n'est pas en
danger c'est une candidate qui n'est pas
inquiétante sur les français et dans un
contexte de crise ça peut parler alain
mérieux s'exprime depuis depuis lyon
avant avant valérie pécresse toussaint
tous les tous les ténors qui prennent la
parole on attend évidemment laurent
wauquiez également on essaiera de
l'écouté peut-être un petit peu si si
les règlements n'a pas pris la parole
avant cela l'importance de ces de ses
meetings ça m'intéresse vraiment savoir
en quoi aujourd'hui à l'épreuve des
réseaux sociaux à l'épreuve de des
débats télévisés ses meetings ont une
importance c'est vrai que c'est
particulièrement important de le dire
plus de 4 français sur 10 s'informent
sur la campagne
présidentiel à travers les réseaux
sociaux donc ça c'est quand même
important avoir en tête c'est que c'est
il ya sa place énormément par les
réseaux sociaux et les bulles sociale
c'est à dire les communautés auprès
desquels on prend de l'information sur
les réseaux sociaux maintenant ces
meetings là où ça a de l'importance sais
pas ce que ça donne l'image quand même
d'une communauté physique mobilisés et
d'un soutien au projet et on a vu parce
que c'est notre projet avec emmanuel
macron très content et très fort dans la
crédibilité des choses ça donne une
dynamique d'ensemble qui est très fort
et ça crédibilise aussi le vote de
premier tour c'est vrai que le premier
tourne pour construire une cohorte de
fidèles et de deux militants ça passe
beaucoup par des meetings par des
rassemblements physique important et
c'est vrai que du coup ça démontre aussi
la force et l'ampleur du rassemblement
un candidat qui fait un meeting de
premier tour devant une salle qui est à
moitié ville c'est nécessairement
négatif pour son image un candidat qui
fait un meeting devant une salle bourrée
à craquer qui déborde c'est forcément
très positif et ça montre que la
mobilisation autour du projet est très
importante peut-être que ces meetings
ont été cette fois encore plus important
je vois anthony qui dit il n'y a pas eu
de bagarre à la à la télé cette année il
y en a eu en amont du meeting d'eric
zemmour c'était à villepinte il n'y a
pas de bagarres comment vous dire entre
hommes politiques à la télévision dans
des débats hi-media paye d'exactement à
dire exactement sensation dans des
débats et 70% des français regrettait qu
emmanuel macron ne participe pas aux 5 %
à 70 % est ce que justement on disait
que l'abstention pouvait être être
record dimanche est ce que c'est à cause
de cela et deuxième question à qui elle
profite l'abstention on a souvent dit
l'abstention elle profite aux extrêmes à
marine le pen parce que c'est encore le
cas aujourd'hui ce qu'on sait alors
l'abstention ce qu'on sait c'est que ça
se partage pour moitié ses 27 % de
français qui compte ne pas aller voter
dimanche ça se partage entre les gens
qui nous disent c'est joué d'avancé et
des gens qui nous disent les
propositions qui sont faites ne
m'intéresse pas ça à moitié moitié sur
la force de l'abstention on sait que
l'abstention allait différentiel elles
touchent en priorité certaines
catégories de population ceux qui
s'abstiennent le plus fortement les
jeunes les employés les ouvriers les
habitants de grande vie les femmes ou
les foyers les plus modestes et du coup
cette population tous les
abstentionnistes ça correspond plus
fortement à l'électorat de marine le pen
tu te se démobiliser plus fortement que
la moyenne de les
segments électoraux qu'elle touche et
puis à l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon
aussi qui est le candidat quel électorat
le plus jeune parmi les douze candidats
l'élection présidentielle vous voyez les
images en direct de lyon avant la
dernière prise de parole de valérie
pécresse on va voir si vous voulez bien
avec avec benjamin délit en régie les
images depuis depuis paris depuis le
palais des sports le meeting d'eric
zemmour c'est nicolas bay un transfuge
du rassemblement national qui s'exprime
est ce que ces nombreuses têtes
d'affiché du rassemblement national qui
ont finalement rejoint marine le pen on
pensa à nicolas bay on pense à sur
ravier on pense même si elle n'était
plus au rassemblement national à marion
maréchal est ce que ça a pu desservir
eric zemmour est au contraire c'est
servir marine le pen on l'a vu peut-être
plus humaine certains moments oui c'est
vrai qu'elle n'est de toute façon dans
ces aliments il ya toujours deux
hypothèses soit c'est un vallon à un
ralliement qui fragilise la personne qui
ait quitté soit c'est un ralliement qui
renforce la personne qui est ralliée par
exemple le ralliement d'eric woerth on
peut imaginer que ça a fragilisé valérie
pécresse d'accord elle a renforcé
emmanuel macron en revanche le
ralliement de alors de nicolas bay mais
aussi de gilbert collard on peut
imaginer que ça a plus renforcée eric
zemmour que sanaa fragilisé marine le
pen d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on a vu dans
les chiffres marine le pen n'a pas été
fragilisées électoralement part c'est
par ces départs mais ça a probablement
renforcer la crédibilité d'eric zemmour
parce que les gens se disent ah mais
attends si marine le pen est devant eric
zemmour dans les sondages mais pourtant
il ya des gens qui rallie eric zemmour
c'est qu'il ya une possibilité que ça
monte c'est qu'ils sentent la dynamique
et donc ça crédibilise donc je pense que
ça à crédibiliser le projet d'eric
zemmour plus que sanaa des services une
marine le pen je cause qui nous
regardent sur youtube et qui nous dit
eric zemmour a fait une très belle
campagne il est sorti de nulle part mais
cette technique marche seulement en
amérique est ce que c'est vrai ce qu'en
france on peut pas avoir quelqu'un qui
sort de nulle part j'en ai dit en 2017
c'est presque ce qui s'est passé ouais
si ces mêmes c'est même tout à fait ce
qui ce qui s'est passé et puis parce que
comme emmanuel macron en 2017 qui ne
sortaient pas totalement de nulle part
eric zemmour ne sort pas totalement de
nulle part non plus il était quand même
connu d'une majorité de français depuis
un bon moment c'est un journal et ce qui
est identifié dans le paysage national
après ce qui a peut-être manqué à eric
zemmour c'est d'ajouter des briques aux
côtés de l'immigration sur les questions
économiques sur les questions sociales
et à aller un peu plus loin pour les
français parce que c'est vrai que
finalement à se tourner dans la
caricature sur les éléments liés à la
mise à l'immigration ça l'a desservi et
ça l'a enfermée dans un segment
électoral dont elle était trop difficile
de sortir sur la fin de la campagne pour
lui guillaume pelletier s'exprime depuis
le meeting d'eric zemmour en attendant
eric zemmour on est toujours est que
erwan lestrohan de l'institut aux docks
ça et on vit ensemble ces derniers
meetings on a écouté tout à l'heure
marine le pen qui était à perpignan
marine le pen qui on l'a senti on peut
le rappeler a
visé et un peu plus emmanuel macron que
les autres tout à l'heure oui c'est vrai
que les c'est aussi parce qu emmanuel
macron et la personnalité centrale du
jeu politique français si on regarde les
mêmes les mentions sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis quelques jours et
l'énorme proportion des mentions vient
parler d' emmanuel macron que ce soit en
positif ou en négatif d'eur c'est même
un peu plus en négatif ces derniers
temps mais c'est vrai qu'ils restent
quand même les talons de la prise de
parole est la référence de la prise de
parole parce qu'il est central dans le
jeu politique français il est le favori
mais c'est vrai que quand marine le pen
se positionne à l'encontre du favori non
seulement elle mobilise ses électeurs à
aller voter contre emmanuel macron mais
aussi elles crédibilisent son projet en
l'opposant et emmanuel macron et en
visant le remake du duel de 2010 c'est
marine le pen qui disait dans le dans le
figaro c'était hier je suis confronté à
deux candidats qui sont des candidats
hémiplégique eric zemmour d'un côté jean
luc mélenchon de l'autre l'un ne
s'intéresse qu'à la protection
civilisationnel le second ne s'intéresse
qu'à la protection sociale je suis la
candidate qui fait les deux elle aussi
c'est une candidate du grand
rassemblement comme l'a été emmanuel
macron en 2017 c'est tout l'enjeu pour
elle en tout cas c'est vraiment de
sortir de cette logique d'affrontement
et d'aller dans le rassemblement et
d'expliquer mais c'est la stratégie des
cercles concentriques du rassemblement
national pour élargir ses soutiens
électoraux qu'elle peut aller au delà de
son coeur électoral qui est pour pour
l'heure beaucoup construit autour de
d'une france qui travaille mais d'une
france précaire et qui subit les
difficultés de la vie emmanuel macron
n'a pas trop parlé mais on va en
discuter un petit peu il était très trop
dans les sondages il ya quelques
semaines il est toujours très haut il
est toujours en tête mais sa baisse
pourquoi alors ce qu'on a observé déjà
dans nos mesures de début mars à
l'encontre d'emmanuel macron c'est un
certain effet de ralliement autour du
drapeau qui lui a fait gagner des points
d'intentions de vote nous était monté
jusqu'à 30 points d'intentions de vote
dans nos sondages au doxa pour loeb ce
parce que il ya une partie de la
population française qui dans ce
contexte des mois d'incertitude de vive
inquiétude s'est rangé derrière un
président protecteur dans une situation
de crise mais on sait que ces effets
aussi peuvent s'essouffler et que
finalement ils tendent à diminuer et
d'ailleurs les baisses des intentions de
vote à emmanuel concerne des populations
qui font pas partie de son socle
électoral des employés et des ouvriers
des ruraux et des habitants de petites
villes des personnes sans proximité
partisane donc finalement c'est
peut-être ce matelas supplémentaire qui
s'était décidé à voter pour emmanuel
macron en période de crise qui dès lors
qu'il est descendu de son estrade et
s'est consacré à la campagne nationale
finalement il est re devenue perméable
aux critiques et donc ça l'a desservi et
on voit les intentions de vote reculer
légèrement le concernant on attend
évidemment valérie pécresse à lyon qui
doit prendre la parole dans un instant
on attendait aussi eric zemmour vous le
voyez qui sera à ce pupitre celui auquel
est actuellement guillaume pelletier en
l'écoutant l'instant et puis on se
retrouve tout de suite après
votre responsabilité est immense car
vous êtes l'avenir du monde et je suis
venu vous dire pourquoi vous allez le
changer vous allez changer le monde
parce que vous avez compris leur jeu
vital de cette élection parce que vous
vous fichez des sondages des
journalistes des experts qui veulent
vous imposer ce que vous devez aimer ce
que vous devez penser ce que vous devez
croire ce que vous devez voter vous
voulez simplement et vous avez tellement
raison que la france reste la france que
la france de nos pères et de nos
grands-pères reste crise économique
ouais
[Applaudissements]
vous allez
vous allez vous allez changer le monde
parce que vous êtes les enfants
politique d'un homme d'exception d'un
français juifs berbères venus d'algérie
d'un homme d'un homme venu de là bas est
tellement amoureux d'ici d'un petit fils
de cordonnier
aujourd'hui candidat de la nation du
plus courageux et du plus honnête des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
d'un homme qui mérite tout notre soutien
et notre enthousiasme et cet homme
s'appelle eric zemmour
[Applaudissements]
à
vous allez
vous vous allez changer le monde
parce que vous êtes les enfants de
philippe de villiers
pouet pouet parmi les poètes
génial créateur du puy-du-fou et du
vendée globe
monties cher philippe qui m'a dit ici il
y a dix sept ans à cet endroit sur cette
même tribune que c'est la fièvre de la
jeunesse qui maintient vivante l'âme du
monde quand la jeunesse se refroidit
c'est le monde entier qui claquent des
dents
vous allez changer le monde parce que
vous avez pleuré au pied de notre dame
en flammes parce que vous voulez parce
que vous voulez chasser les lobbys lgbt
de nos écoles
parce que vous vous lever quand vous
chanter la marseillaise parce que vous
vibrer quand vous voyez flotter au vent
le drapeau tricolore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il à
à
non
la marseillaise
meeting d'eric zemmour et laurent
wauquiez ci s'exprime avant valérie
pécresse a lyon je vous propose qu'on
les écoute un petit peu lui aussi on n'a
pas forcément beaucoup entendu durant
cette campagne on va l'entendre un petit
peu
voilà laurent wauquiez
porter des idées de la droite nous avons
eu le courage de faire des économies
peut-être un brin de tempérament
auvergnats dauphinois au choix nous
n'avons pas entretenu l'illusion de
l'argent magique et tu es la seule dans
cette campagne ne pas avoir promis tout
et n'importe quoi je vois revenir je
vois revenir dans cette campagne
présidentielle avec préoccupation cette
époque que nous avons bien connu dans
les années 80 et 90 où un candidat
promène tout et n'importe quoi avant les
élections présidentielles tellement
facile de faire des cadeaux mac ou de
ristournes sur le litre de l'essence
alors même bruno et vous l'avez montré
que l'état empoché près du double des
recettes fiscales tellement facile
d'augmenter les fonctionnaires ou
d'annoncer la revalorisation des
retraites comme par hasard juste avant
les élections je n'ai aucune estime pour
cette façon de faire de la politique
bien géré tu l'as fait la tête de marée
et nous le ferons avec toi pour la
france
[Applaudissements]
nous ici valérie nous sommes du côté des
forces de l'ordre lorsqu un festival de
musique alliant prônent la haine de la
police nous arrêtons immédiatement tout
soutien lorsque sciences po grenoble
dans une dérive islamo-gauchiste
préoccupante sanctionne un professeur
qui a le courage de dénoncer l'islamisme
au lendemain de l'attentât de samuel
pâtit nous arrêtons toutes formes de
collaboration
et lorsqu un soi-disant institut
culturel musulman à lyon financé par
l'arabie saoudite cautionnée par le
ministre de l'intérieur de l'époque
castaner nous refusons de cautionner
cette lâcheté je n'oublie pas valérie
que tu as eu le même courage et que tu
interdit le port du burkini dans les
piscines parce que la laïcité est
l'identité de la france ça ne se négocie
pas merci de ton courage
et
tu es ici dans une région valérie qui
est une grande région industrielle
ici on produit on innove on fabrique
français merci alain et s'il me le
permet si elle me le permet merci à
chantal merci de ce que vous êtes tous
les deux parce que vous montrer qu'il
peut y avoir un entrepreneuriat qui
réussit qui est fait preuve d'audace
mais qui rend toujours à son pays ce qui
lui a donné merci à tous les deux
d'avoir défendu la cause des chrétiens
d'orient en syrie et en irak merci
d'avoir porté la voix des minorités et
merci d'accueillir comme vous le faites
les réfugiés ukrainien dans notre
progression merci à tous les deux fait
si fiers de ce que vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
et nous cela a été dit comme toi nous
récompensons l'effort nous avons rétabli
dans nos régions les bourses au mérite
pour les étudiants que françois hollande
et emmanuel macron avait supprimé ici
cher michel dans ce territoire où la
montagne nous rappelle tout le temps que
nous sommes le territoire de l'effort et
de la ténacité nous croyons dans le
travail valérie est la seule à porter un
programme de revalorisation du travail
il y a dix ans lorsque j'avais dénoncé
le danger du cancer de l'assistanat que
de critiques n'avaient entendu je n'ai
pas changé d'avis aujourd'hui nous y
sommes dans cette déconstruction du
rapport au travail merci à valérie
d'être la seule à tenir l'idée que quand
on a des droits on a des devoirs et
qu'en contrepartie du rsa les
bénéficiaires doivent faire des heures
d'intérêt général ce qui n'est pas une
peine
et pour ceux d'entre vous qui aurez
besoin de comprendre les différences
emmanuel macron à peine avait-il estimé
l'idée de ces heures d'intérêt général
en contrepartie du rsa immédiatement il
avait fait marche arrière tout effrayé
par sa propre audace en même temps
[Applaudissements]
et bien tout ceci valérie c'est
important parce que c'est le gage que ce
que tu as fait tu le feras le doute ne
vous y trompez pas raphaël tu le sais
bien le doute n'est pas par rapport à
nos idées nos idées sont majoritaires en
france elles n'ont jamais été aussi
majoritaires mais le doute par rapport à
nous est-ce qu'ils le feront est-ce
qu'on peut encore le faire est-ce qu'il
ya encore des politiques dans ce pays
qui ont le courage de renverser la table
et d'aller jusqu'au bout pourquoi il est
important d'expliquer ce que nous
faisons pourquoi il est important
d'expliquer ce que valérie a fait parce
que le meilleur gage qu'il aura la même
détermination à la tête de l'état c'est
qu'elle a déjà enclenché ce travail dans
sa région ile-de-france comme nous
l'avons fait en auvergne rhône-alpes
c'est pour ça que vous pouvez lui faire
confiance
et en face
quelle étrange campagne
quel vide
quel manque d'intérêt tout est fait pour
qu'on ne puisse pas avoir ce réflexe de
survie dont albert camus maman on
parlait lorsqu'il écrivait au chambon
sur lignon voir dire la vérité la vérité
sur l'état du pays la vérité sur les
menaces du communautarisme la vérité
aussi sur les atouts incroyable dont
recèle christophe la france pour que
nous retrouvions nos valeurs et bien
emmanuel macron a tout fait dans cette
campagne pour camoufler la vérité
voilà un président dont la campagne a
consisté à esquiver les français à
refuser les débats à détourner
l'attention ap et anisé les esprits il a
voulu se passer de campagne il a voulu
faire l'impasse de la démocratie et ce
choix aura de lourdes conséquences pour
la suite
mais je voudrais vous poser une question
pourquoi cela que cherche-t-il donc à
éviter
est ce qu'il ne veut pas être très
simple ce qu'il ne peut pas c'est que
les français ne puissent pas se poser
cette question qui est pourtant si
fondamental au moment d'une élection
présidentielle
notre pays va t'il mieux qu'il ya cinq
ans
la situation en france s'est elle
améliorée par rapport à il ya cinq ans
les choses ont elles progressé
et bien lors de son meeting de samedi
emmanuel macron s'est livré à un
exercice d'autosatisfaction indécent
avec une litanie du nous l'avons fait
mais qu'at-il donc fait réformer l'état
et supprimer les gaspillages il ne l'a
pas vrai valoriser le travail plutôt que
l'assistanat il ne l'a pas fait sauver
nos retraites plutôt que de baisser les
pensions il ne l'a pas fait redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux français qui ne l'a
pas fait non
arrêter l'immigration qui ceinturent nos
capacités d'assimilation il ne l'a pas
fait construire des bases de prison il
ne l'a pas fait rennes perd lente il ne
l'a pas fait tout ce qu'il n'a pas fait
il me promet aujourd'hui les mêmes
causes produiront toujours les mêmes
effets
[Applaudissements]
le en même temps
le en même temps c'est la synthèse molle
le en même temps si rien ne change
écoutons ce que disait blaise pascal
ce grand philosophe né dans notre région
il y a quatre siècles génie des
mathématiques qui au xviie siècle
invente la première machine à calculer
esprit libre qui ne s'était jamais
soumis devant louis xiv et coton pascal
dans les paroles résonnent avec une
étrange actualité
pascal dénonçaient ces demies habile
entretenant une doctrine des équivoques
ceux qui se plaignent de parole et vous
sert d opinion contraire ceux qui
veulent attirer tout le monde et ne
rebute et personnes sont dont la pensée
est maniable à tous sens et capables de
toutes sortes de formes et bien mes amis
voilà le en même temps voilà ce que nous
ne voulons plus pour la france
[Applaudissements]
le badema
et dans cette femme comprennent pas ça
va réveiller sortir cette vieille
antienne de la politique française
depuis mitterrand faute de milan est
faux de projet et c'est pour cela que je
souhaite finir le président sortant peu
cyniquement se poser comme souvent face
aux extrémistes le même discours qui
depuis des années prive en réalité les
français de choix
ne vous laissez pas enfermer dans le
même scénario qu'il y a cinq ans entre
macron et le pen ne laissez pas le même
piège se refermer ne laissez pas
immobilisme gagner la stratégie d'
emmanuel macron une terrible car elle
prive les français de toutes
alternatives politiques et le gers vous
n'avez pas le soir car c'est moi ou le
vertige des extrêmes je vais vous forcer
à voter pour moi malgré vous et bien
c'est un mensonge vous avez toujours le
choix vous n'êtes jamais condamné à 7
ans parce vous avez une toujours le soir
non la haine de la france ne se résume
pas à une alternative entre un
soi-disant du progrès contre un soi
disant qu'en du nationalisme il y a
toujours un autre chemin possible je
suis convaincu que c'est celui que le
port valérie dont celle comparaître fait
le choix de la droite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la question où la france
n'est en effet pas dans cette opposition
entre les forces du bien et soit disant
les forces du mal ni l'une ni l'autre
plus le réel se dégrader plus emmanuel
macron fait retentir des imprécations
messianique dans un double mouvement
doublé du passé et de supplique vers
l'avenir il nous dit tout s'est dégradé
mais demain sera meilleur qu'aujourd'hui
il pourrait dire plus trivialement j'ai
tout bousiller mais faites moi confiance
pour les issues de secours
je ne fais pas confiance
et de son côté marine le pen bluffant
tombe bien c'est le risque du chaos
la tentation de renverser la table mais
surtout le danger de tout détruire je ne
veux ni immobilisme ni la description
l'avenir du pays n'est pas là le choix
dans cette présidentielle n'est pas
enfermé entre le progrès n'est la nation
nous n'avons pas à choisir entre la
raison et la folie entre l'espoir et le
désespoir
la vraie question n'est pas là la vraie
question c'est celle infiniment plus
poignant infiniment plus existentielle
comment arrêtons la déconstruction de
notre pays si tout simplement nous
comprenions que notre devoir est de
préserver ce qui nous a été transmis
veiller sur ce qui fait la france patrie
de la seule gloire la question ses
ventes ont continué à laisser notre pays
s'abîmer nous voulons reconstruire la
question entre le délitement et le
sursaut entre la déconstruction et la
reconstruction entre la décadence et la
renaissance
les français aspirent à ce que l'on
retrouve nos valeurs les français
aspirent à ce que l'on redonne des
fondations les français aspirent à ce
que l'on arrête ce bout fou qui nous a
conduits à mettre à terre ce qui faisait
la force de notre pays les français
aspirent à ce que l'on retrouve le
l'autisme et la fierté qui font les
qualités naturelles de notre pays le
travail la culture et la liberté alors
oui ne vous laissez pas enfermer dans la
réédition du scénario de 2010 cents ne
vous laissez pas consisté votre choix ne
vous laissez pas voler notre destin
imposez votre liberté faites vous
entendre
mobilisez-vous fait résonner la voix de
la france
cette élection
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez aux passionnés
et maintenant le moment est venu d'agir
sur scène une femme
courageuse et studieuse
et est passible à s'exprimer dans
maintenant
laurent wauquiez sont sous préfète
dernier ces derniers grands meetings de
campagne on jette un oeil on garde un
oeil sur ce qui se passe du côté du
palais des sports à paris où eric
zemmour devrait s'exprimer dans les
instants qui viennent également mais
maintenant on écoute valérie pécresse la
candidate des républicains à la
présidence
[Musique]
michel naviguait bonheur
quel bonheur de voir une salle comble
ici
et surtout et surtout aux chalands un
soir de match donc alors frédéric dard
frédéric dard que vous connaissez le
père de san antonio qui est né si je ne
me trompe de bourgoin jallieu
frédéric dabi est à lyon la vraie
lumière devient pas dans vos ailes liens
du coeur des lyonnais
alors des amis aujourd'hui c'est avec
mon coeur que je vais vous parlez pour
vous dire que vraiment tous je vous aime
et un grand merci
un grand merci pour cette fabuleuse
campagne qui va prendre fin demain soir
pour le premier tour ce premier tour où
nous allons faire mentir tous les
sondages tous les pronostiqueurs tous
les commentateurs tous ceux qui se sont
toujours trompés
ici le sort à nyon
saveurs cabinet l'école somme de la
ville de lar danse nous sommes dans la
ville de jean moulin est donc ici on
sait on sait ce que résister veut dire
et moi je voudrais commencer évidemment
pas avoir une pensée puisqu'on parle de
résistance pour l'extraordinaire
résistance du peuple ukrainien et je
crois que michel barnier on a parlé avec
mon flickr michel dumas vous maniez
nouvelle campagne du début jusqu'à la
fin parce que c'est très important
il faut pouvoir si je suis élue
présidente de la république si les
français me font confiance il faut
pouvoir changer une capitaine ils vont
pouvoir changer de président de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne en cours de route il faut
pouvoir reprendre des négociations
diplomatiques extrêmement tendue pour
espérer enfin obtenir des résultats il
faut tracer une route vers la baie celle
ci oblige elle que nous avions déjà
esquissé en janvier
alors oui je voudrais vous dire ici que
nous sommes tous ukrainiens
et je voulais vous dire aussi que je
sais dans celle de belles kalinda
lyonnaise qu'
il ya une tradition qu'il ya une
tradition chrétienne et humaniste qui
est celle de l'accueil qui est celle de
l'accueil des réfugiés tu vas parler
cher laurent des chrétiens d'orient moi
je voulais vous dire ici que j'ai été
très choqué il ya un candidat dans cette
campagne eric zemmour pas le nommer qui
a dit pas la guerre
a démarré que nous pourrions ne pas
accueillir de réfugiés chrétiens sur
notre sol
eh bien ça n'est pas notre droite ça
n'est pas la droite la droite elle
initie de renouer riel
et quand elle voit des images
bouleversantes des charniers de boudhha
elle se demande pas si ce sont des
fausses si mal et si ça n'est pas un
complot notre droit elle n'aime pas d'un
boutiques françaises notre droit
c'est ça c'est vrai nous sommes dit
d'elle
alors je suis heureux d'être ici il ya
tellement d'élus qui sont présents
tellement de fidèles c'est le rendez
vous de l'amitié c'est le rendez-vous de
la fidélité et vous êtes venus de tous
les douze départements de la région
rhône alpes auvergne alors laurent
matinée les sites pas tous tu vas en
oublier alors je lui ai seacret malice
mais je voudrais leur dire vraiment à
tous à tous les parlementaires à tous
les présidents de départements à tous
les élus qui sont ici que j'allais même
si infiniment d'être à mes côtés il y en
a qui viennent je vois raphaël berger
d'assas il y en a qui viennent même yann
nadine morano qui vient du grand monde
est petit qu'un homme ya julien aux
baleines qui vient du mot clusaz il ya
tous ceux qui viennent d'ailleurs et
puis il ya aussi
[Musique]
et bonjour le titanic
il y avait même j'ai vu le jura j'ai vu
jean marie sermier
j'ai vu marie-christine chaubet milhas
et français de partout dans cette salle
la gironde il y a des amis depardieu qui
sont ici mais moi ce que je voudrais
dire j'aurais dire à brice hortefeux que
je suis très sensible au soutien qu'il
m'a apporté depuis le début de cette
campagne
[Applaudissements]
je retiens qu'il n' formidable président
de l'assemblée nationale et que avec lui
nous avons bâti un nouveau blanco liens
de renouveau nucléaire pour la france
je voudrais dire bruno retailleau que
les cent jours que nous avons ensemble
écrit sont les 100 premiers jours dans
lesquelles nous allons tout changer en
france
parce que nous notre projet lestrem il
écrit il est sifflé crédible et c'est à
ça qu'on vous reconnaît parce que nous
sommes un parti de gouvernement nous
sommes l'alternance nous sommes la
rupture avec emmanuel macron la seule
l'unique la seule crédible et une prêt à
gouverner dans les 100 jours
et puis je voudrais dire ma tanière
à damien baden qu'il a été un formidable
président du groupe à l'assemblée
nationale que je sais que c'est un des
métiers les plus ingrats qui soit n'est
ce pas bernard mais que les députés les
députés sont des hommes et des femmes
engagés fidèles mais déterminée et qui
sont aujourd'hui tous derrière moi et je
les en remercie
cette campagne plus tôt mattel
des démos jal n'a pas eu lieu et la
gamme imac reviennent et lester assez
peu rempli alors je le dis merci damien
bravo temporal parce que l'infidélité
bravo de parler avec moi l'égalité des
chances pour chaque enfant de france
alors merci à tous mes amis du rhône
merci à françois noël buffet berlin
élevé à nathalie serre à 90 folco à
christophe guilloteau américain s'est
dit à pierre oliver
qui m'a fait confiance depuis tellement
longtemps à pascal me lâche et un
bouchon à dominique nachury mon ancien
collègue yves cochet avis meunier à
isabella mur je m'aperçois que j'ai
oublié michel zoah qui nous vient des
alpes-maritimes
maciek saviez breton achard de la même
pierre a suivi goy chavent à patrick
chaize je voudrais saluer ici et
allemands talons mathieu darnaud fabrice
bien olivier herrmann changer une bonne
idée en dycker et bruno faure pour le
camp d'al emmanuel antoine marie pierre
mouton pour l'atome frédérique puissat
michel savin pour l'isère dino cinieri
vers la bonne
lors du blond
lionel chauvin louis giscard d'estaing
la savoie et minimaux nivat main sans
volant un petit de mêlée terne où
belletti vient génie du bi muller et
puis je m'aperçois qu'il y en a deux
autres que je n'ai pas cités qui ont eu
un rôle très important dans cette
campagne laurent duplomb palombes à
laurent duplomb dicko l'amt et diversité
nicolas lacroix pardon le président du
conseil départemental de la haute marne
et qui a aidé à mes côtés l'auteur de
notre projet sur la décentralisation et
la départementalisation et puis j'ai
mouillé philippe bouyer les deux sphères
qui est là mais koné a travaillé surtout
notre projet handicap parce que le sujet
du handicap
eh bien nous l'avons au coeur et nous
voulons que chaque français puisse avoir
la même dignité nous allons desgranges
égaliser l'allocation adulte handicapé
pour faire en sorte que cette prestation
devienne une prestation de compensation
du handicap et je vous remercie 12 et je
sais philippe tabarot parce qu'en fait
quand on atteindrait selon deux pour le
prix d'un le sénateur philippe tabarot
qui est aussi parmi nos
à wil orange les halls et finit par les
citer tous parce que mais pourquoi j'ai
décidé tous j'ai décidé tous parce que
ils sont venus ils sont là et que
vraiment aujourd'hui nous sommes tous
réunis et que ça fait plaisir à voir
alors je voudrais aussi dire un mot
aviatrice de monty et un mot alain
mérieux
alain chantal merci votre amitié merci
votre fidélité merci d'être sorti de la
niche merci d'avoir repris le flambeau
de la politique merci à vous même si
belle reese tu feras une formidable
députés et moi aussi je serai là pour
toi et bien dernier mot à tous nos chers
mais ce dernier mot je le leur dirai la
fin de mon discours mais les jeunes ont
été
extraordinaires dans c'est normal
[Applaudissements]
bravo les jeunes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et merci il est merci pour tout tu as
été un formidable quand on parle
[Applaudissements]
alors
moi je voulais vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
c'est est un plaisir de faire cette
dernière réunion ici à lyon parce que
c'est la région de laurent wauquiez et
que le rock est un homme de conviction
c'est un homme de conviction
ce n'est pas un homme de compromission
et vous savez bien une tellement dans
cette campagne de trahison de kouba
d'attac et moi je tiens à le dire les
convictions c'est beaucoup plus
important que les compromissions et ici
nous sommes pour un mode de convictions
que j'appelle les français
conviction j'ajoute que le rwanda
coureur de fond et ne sait mieux que
personne que vient échouer avant la
ligne d'arrivée
alors mes chers amis qu'est-ce que quel
est mon message aujourd'hui eh bien mon
message il est simple
ne vous laissez pas voler cette élection
ne vous laissez pas
cette victoire nos idées sont
majoritaires nominés sont seigle pays
majoritaires
liberté le pays attend du pouvoir
d'achat la valorisation du travail le
pays attend de la puissance et une
laisse souveraineté ils nous attendent
patriote et européen avec une autre robe
dans laquelle se défendre on vraiment
les intérêts de la france vous le savez
mais celle d'un ami j'ai dit à un moment
donné que j'étais te tiens merkel un
tiers thatcher et pourquoi est ce que je
dis ça parce que toutes les deux elles
sont défendues bec et ongles donnent
toute leur force leur et que c'est assad
doit servir une présidente de la
république
défendre de toutes ses forces le peuple
français est aujourd'hui le peuple
français n'est pas défendu il n'est pas
allé devant dieu sait quand il m'a trop
long les spots et un plan de la ferme à
la chaîne qui organise la décroissance
agricole de notre pays la décroissance
agricole j'étais aujourd'hui dans les
vignes du beaujolais mais quand cela
alors que nous avons aujourd'hui une
alimentation qui fait notre fierté qui
fait notre fierté qu'il faut aussi nous
excédents de balance commerciale c'est à
dire qui est un trésor national
nous ne pouvons pas accepter la
décroissance agricole d'emmanuel macro
nous reviendrons sur ce projet de ferme
à la prochaine car en plein
réchauffement climatique la france doit
produire et nos agriculteurs doivent
pouvoir assurer à l'aise
[Applaudissements]
alors
emmanuel macron est un président qui a
escamoté la campagne il a indiqué la
campagne il a privé les français le
débat il ya deux jours il y avait un
débat sur une grande chaîne du service
public france 2 il n'est pas venu il
n'est pas venu et le service public a
retransmis sa propagande électorale à la
place est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un pour
s'en indigner est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un
pour dire que on assiste à un simulacre
de campagne électorale et bien moi je
vous le dis on ne peut pas faire
campagne en toisant les français du
balcon de l'elysée alors qu'aucun
ministre du gouvernement n'a été
autorisé à débattre avec moi pendant
cette campagne c'est ça la réalité
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont peur que je
des masques leur bilan calamiteux parce
qu'ils sont peur que je montre la
puissance du projet d'une droite
républicaine forte sur ses malheurs
pourquoi ont-ils refusé le débat il
avait des problèmes d'agenda
pour la comme ils ont toujours rendez
vous mais comme celle de rendre des
comptes aux français alors là y'a plus
personne nous avons eu un président
illusionnisme mes chers amis et
maintenant nous avons un candidat en vie
et bien maintenant ce candidat en 10 il
vous reste trois jours trois jours pour
aller débusquer les ambiguïtés du en
même temps parce que le en même temps
c'est le paravent de l'impuissance
publique et c'est ta puissance publique
elle conduit tous trois victoires des
extrêmes par ce temps le peuple est en
colère alors tout devient possible et
même le pire alors il faut mettre fin à
l'impuissance publique et ivo dévoiler
les ambiguïtés du en même temps vous
avez bien vu ce emmanuel macron il a
commencé par dire on va reprendre des
idées de la droite
la retraite à 65 ans la réforme n'a pas
fait nous allons la faire le lendemain à
la télévision il a annoncé deux ans et
demi une concertation
alors les retraités qui ont été les
grands sacrifiés ce quinquennat qui ont
vu leur retraite pc d indexer et bien
les retraités parce qu'il ya une réforme
il est le seul président de la
république qui dans son mandat n'a fait
aucune réforme des retraites et
aujourd'hui il nous en annonce une pour
deux jours après explique et qui va
d'abord concertée il ne fera pas cette
réforme il ne tiendra pas l'appareil qui
n'a pas de nous on ne peut pas lui faire
confiance aujourd'hui j'ajoute que
j'ai demandé
l'indexation automatique des retraites
parce que nous avons une inflation très
importante et bien il est d'aller le
proposait hier à la télévision c'est un
président sans idée c'est un président
du plagiat et tu mauvais plagiat sur les
réserves sur le laisse à
15 heures d'activités obligatoire en
contrepartie du rsa pour revaloriser le
travail c'est notre idée il l'a comme
pis on lui dit par an mais c'est l'idée
de la droite edit ah non mais c'est pas
du tout pareil moi ce sera volontaire
est pas obligatoire
et oui mais si c'est volontaire ça veut
dire que personne ne le fera ça veut
dire que rien ne changera le même temps
vous savez
j'avais ce que disait mitterrand
françois mitterrand disait on ne sort de
l'ambiguïté qu'à son détriment
et bien c'est pour ça qu'ils emmanuel
macron fuit le débat c'est parce qu'il
ne veut pas sortir de l'ambiguïté dans
laquelle miley de ce mandat des
déceptions et des abandons alors vous
savez et unième macron n'est pas de
droite samedi dernier
dans son meeting pas un mot sur le
druide est pas un mot sur les migrations
par motion lors au alain l'a très bien
dit notre vie a besoin d'un choc
d'autorité toutes les figures d'autorité
en france aujourd'hui sont pas fous et
toutes les figures d'autorité et les
maires et forces de l'ordre les
professeurs les médecins les pompiers et
pourtant tout va bien semble dire
emmanuel macron ici nous sommes à lyon
nous sommes à lyon où le jeune marin
sauvage on a voulu protéger un troupeau
et a été sauvagement agressé il ya
quelques jours a été dévoilé
l'abominable le passage à tabac du jeune
jérémy cohen à bobby nous avons tant de
françaises qui sont aujourd'hui par les
transports en commun nous avons donc
deux policiers qui sont pris pour cible
l'autre jour j'étais avec
avec pierrot heures dans le quartier de
la duchère et on a rencontré un policier
s'était fait agresser classement sans
suite classement sans suite est bien
avec moi je peux vous dire l'autorité on
la choisira pas un jour sur deux et moi
je n'y vais pas accuser les postes de
lors de violences policières qu'elle
longeait
m
[Applaudissements]
et c'est pareil pour les madones quand
je vois que l'état tonnes d'oignons
peuvent peuvent passer en direct dans
une émission de télévision et que le
ministre de l'intérieur ne va pas chômer
à la sortie de l'émission jeudi elle est
où l'autorité aller où la république
alors avec nous la république elle sera
partout chez elle et nous remettrons de
l'homme dans les quartiers dans lesquels
aujourd'hui
dans lesquels aujourd'hui on a les zones
de non-droit et vend même disons comme
en france alors non l'insécurité n'est
pas un fantasme monsieur le garde des
sceaux l'insécurité est une réalité et
nous avec nous ce sera l'impunité seo
et nous avons un plan d'urgence pour la
justice pour lui permettre de juger vie
et bien et nous modifier mon la
constitution pour avoir des peines ferme
d'un an de prison minimale lorsqu'on
s'en prendre à quelqu'un dia automne des
publics
[Applaudissements]
dimanche mes chers amis c'est quelque
chose de beaucoup plus important qui se
joue c'est pas seulement les titans de
la droite c'est la france c'est savoir
si nous allons rester ou pas une grande
puissance mais c'est savoir si nous
allons aussi résister une grande nation
une nation ernest renan disait c'est un
peuple qui a envie d'avoir un destin
commun est-ce que nous sommes encore
aujourd'hui une nation unie qui a envie
d'avoir un destin commun et qui est
fière de son identité
souvenez-vous gérard collomb ou ministre
de l'intérieur a quitté gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron et il a dit aujourd'hui
nous vivons côte à côte demain j'ai peur
que nous vivions face à face et bien moi
je ne veux pas d'une france on vit pas
ça va je ne veux pas d'une grosse prime
sur et je veux une nation unie chaume
une nation réconciliée
mais ça veut dire quoi à mes amis
mes amis ça veut dire qui va me falloir
être implacable avec les prêcheurs de
haine avec tous ceux qui veulent faire
passer leur foi au dessus de la loi
parce que pour nous c'est la république
et les prêcheurs de haine ce sera en
prison ou dans l'avion
l'islamisme et un totalitarisme et nous
lutterons piatti contre lyn
alors vous avez compris vous avez
compris le scénario cilic qui emmanuel
macron veut nous imposer il veut nous
imposer
un face à face avec les extrêmes au
deuxième tour car c'est son assurance
réélection je dis bien de cette tour
deuxième tour parce que pour l'instant
il lésés par le soigneusement
savait depuis janvier que je suis que
vous êtes vous êtes les hommes et les
femmes à battre parce que pas question
pour emmanuel macron d'avoir une droite
républicaine
ford est fier ses malheurs cette droite
n'en veut pas
marine le pen parce que c'est son
assurance réélection alors moi je suis
venu vous le dire ici et je vous le dis
il n'y a qu'un seul homme de droit
dimanche entre l'immobilisme et
l'extrémisme il n'y a qu'une seule
troisième fois et cette troisième mois
c'est nous
[Applaudissements]
le vrai le frère de aux extrémistes le
parti donne la marine le pen dont le
projet amènerait le pays au désordre à
la puissance et à la faillite le vrai
andy noise à l excès moore qui a choisi
poutine lp d'un camp nou ni choisissons
l'ukraine et de gaulle le frère antidote
le vrai anti nomme à ceux qui disent que
tout est foutu c'est la scion c'est le
courage de le faire et ce courage là
vous m'avez vu trébucher
vous m'avez fait continuer vous me
connaissez vous connaissez mon mental de
fer chez ce mental parce que je veux
présider la france c'est parce que nous
sommes prêts après si tu es la france
est ce que personne ne m'enlèvera outre
caractère certains disent mauvais
autrement mais ne t'ai pas loin du
caractère
son effort de femmes voilà
outre mongai des personnes morales
famine avec kim de force qui est autour
de moi une équipe de professionnels une
équipe qu emmanuel macron encore insulté
aujourd'hui en expliquant que nous
étions un parti d'élus locaux comme si
même élu local c'est d'être une injure
et bien élu local cet acompte et
d'engueulades l'élu local se préoccuper
des français est l'élu local s'est
trouvé des solutions tous les jours au
quotidien avec le problème écrit du
local c'est la note si les gens
[Applaudissements]
alors je vous le dis mes amis et je le
vois tous les français qui nous écoutent
refuser ces deux impasses refusé
l'immobilisme du pouvoir en place
renault fusée la démagogie des extrêmes
révoltez vous contre ces fausses ailes
ces imposteurs
c'est ce qui vous dise circulez ya rien
à voir et bien si tout est à voir et à
revoir
imité dimanche prochain c'est le premier
tour c'est pas le second au premier tour
on choisit au second tour en élimine au
premier tour imposez votre liberté a
posé le seul homme de droite
[Applaudissements]
alors oui
puissance à puissance militaire parce
que moi je les ai assez de voir mon pays
humiliés ça a été très bien dit l'image
la france n'a jamais été aussi mauvaise
en afrique or le destin de la france et
du continent africain sont liés nous
devons rétablir la fierté française
partout dans le monde mais on ne
respecte pas à l'extérieur un pays qui
est faible à l'intérieur et c'est pour
ça qu'il faudra avoir le bois en forme
c'est pour ça qu'il nous faut une
balance commerciale excédentaire et non
pas déficitaires de 85 milliards d'euros
c'est pour ça qu'il faut remettre de
l'ordre dans nos rues c'est pour ça
qu'il faut faire respecter nos
frontières avec des quotas migratoires
qui rappelleront s'être est immuable
hospitalité on ne rentre chez quelqu'un
que quand on a été invités
et les clandestins de rentrer
rentrer chez eux
chez eux n'est pour les pays qui ne les
reprenne pas ce sera zéro visa
[Applaudissements]
et j'en profite de mes chers amis
puisque c'est notre dernier meeting jean
robin pour vous demander de faire une
ovation à l'eau 58 militaires sa grande
fille d'à français qui ont donné leur
vie au mali
pour protéger le peuple malien et le sel
que l'islamisme et je ne m'implique je
suis une femme de belles mais que je
souhaite une femme danyellah s'il le
faut lance que les intérêts de la france
seront menacés et que les missions pour
les services qu'il s'en venait et d'une
mission qui est essentiel est qu avec
quoi elle continuera
[Applaudissements]
alors mes chers amis
[Musique]
je veux aussi rendre le pouvoir français
rendre le pouvoir français ça veut dire
les ib je veux une france forte sur
l'autorité mais je veux aussi une france
plus libre
or le voir aux français ça veut dire les
libérer de ses 400 milles d'hommes qui
les empêche de créer moi j'ai été très
frappée de voir cher alors que stéphanie
mancel ancien du biomérieux a été créée
modern à boston et pas à lyon il a été
créé modern à la starten du vaccin à
bolton parce que c'est plus facile de
créer son entreprise aux états unis
alors oui moi je créerai un comité de la
bâche et nous mettrons vingt cinq cent
mille nord qui verrouille melli garonne
film français encore aujourd'hui dans
les mines du coach hellène on m'a attiré
mon attention sur des aberrations
administratives du but et nous
changerons tout ça nous allons libérer
les français de ces normes et puis nous
allons les mails lnd et les toits aussi
parce que je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec l'idée que c'est dans les
territoires que l'action sera la plus
efficace il faut désormais que l'état
lâche prise et il va falloir
décentralisée moi je ne veux pas de
paris ndr français je veux une france
aux multiples capital et je le dis ici à
lyon capitale des gaules jeu aujourd'hui
comme tous les territoires tous les
terroirs discret lyonnais jeu que les
maires retrouve la possibilité de
dessiner
et nous supprimerons ces lois qui les
grottes comme la loi sru et nous ferons
des vrais tradé mixité sociale
pour une france de propriétaires
et randonnées primauté dans le logement
social aux travailleurs première ligne
qui le méritent puis je veux aussi
prendre l'argent aux français leur
argent presque toutes les formes que la
droite a rêvé de faire et qu'elle n'a
pas fait parce que malheureusement nous
n'avons pas gagné les élections et qu
emmanuel macron n'a rien fait lorsqu'on
la réforme de l'état la décentralisation
la réforme de l'assurance chômage la
réforme des retraites et celle d'argent
nous allons leur donner en français je
veux que le travail paye je veux qu'ils
bm plus que l'assistanat je veux monter
les salaires dame dit mme vous ressemble
et ça commencera dès cet été avec une
hausse de 3% des salaires nets est comme
cela les français sont que leur travail
est valorisée est revenu les rtt pour
moins de transformer en salaires les
heures supplémentaires seront
intégralement défiscalisées et je veux
aussi le vrai politique familiale parce
que la famille la famille mes chers amis
c'est le pilier sur lequel nous devons
construire la société et d'hommes qui
dix ans françois hollande emmanuel
macron ont abîmé la politique familiale
et nous avons besoin de reconstruire
cette politique alors oui nous la
reconstruirons avec des allocations
universelles dès le premier enfant et
une augmentation des allocations pour le
deuxième et le troisième enfant et je
veux que les familles soit davantage et
des jeux
c'est dans la famille liot soit reconnue
cheveux que pour nos aînés qu'on puisse
rester à domicile aussi longtemps qu'on
le souhaite et je veux aussi qu'on
transmed qu'on transmet notre histoire
transmet nos valeurs qu'on transmet
notre culture oui je me bats je me bats
michel hamy contre c'est déboulonneurs
de statut contredit ceux qui veulent des
construire notre histoire contre ce
président de la république accusé la
france d' un crime contre l'humanité
qu'elle n'a jamais commis à président de
la république a dit qu'il n'y avait pas
une culture française tt culture en
france un président de la république
qui
un président de la république qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas celui une
république unie mais celui une
république communautariser d'une
république en miettes alors non
aujourd'hui disons non aux extrémistes
mais disons nous aussi à céder le
constructeur de l'histoire ce que tu as
fait laurent à l'université de grenoble
est remarquable et moi aussi je me may
dans ma région pour que la laïcité
l'emportent sur l'islam ou de schiste a
dit jamie qu'ils veulent pendant ce que
des conspirent la france
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis nous allons reconstruire
l'école de la république parce que
aujourd'hui chaque enfant de france doit
avoir sa chance et il n'aime pas normal
qu'il faille six générations aujourd'hui
pour un enfant d'ouvrier beau devenir
cadre l'école la république y aider
notre fierté aujourd'hui et notre
défaite alors oui on va tout
reconstruire on va reconstruire les
fondamentaux le français les
mathématiques un examen avant l'entrée
en sixième et pour ce qu'il rate durera
une sixième de consolidation au collège
parce que ça sert à rien d'apprendre la
physique ou l'anglais quand on sait pas
parler français et faire les 4
opérations et puis nous allons lutter
contre le décrochage scolaire je veux
une réserve éducative nationale comme il
y a une réserve de la gendarmerie
nationale je me compte rémunère des
volontaires retraités étudiants active
pour qu'elles puissent faire du soutien
scolaire gratuit pour toutes les
familles et je confierai l'orientation
région parce que jeune fille revaloriser
l'enseignement professionnel et
l'apprentissage les lycées
professionnels
l'ensemble des corps de métiers
viendront dans les collèges parce que
nous avons besoin aujourd'hui que nos
jeunes à une vers les métiers qui
recrutent et certainement pas des sages
elles à 500 euros par mois pour aller se
lever à accompagner ambitions locales ce
que nous voulons aujourd'hui c'est les
jeunes qui vont faire un centre
ce centre est
et ce sera nous qui les y remet à
l'ombre
alors oui avec nous il y aura deux fois
plus de réformes avec emmanuel macron il
y aura deux fois plus belles dames beau
et je veux parler un petit peu de nos
retraités parce que nous retraités ont
été les grands oubliés de ce quinquennat
et avec la réforme des retraites que je
vais faire on passera le minimum
retraite à 1000 euros et je me prends
l'engagement que plus beau qu'un
retraité qui aura cotisé toute sa vie ne
partira avec une retraite inférieure au
smic
et quant aux veuves parce que ce sont
souvent des verts qui n'ont pas pu
travaillé toute leur vie je pense aux
veuves d'artisans de commerçants
agriculteurs je pense aussi à ces veuves
qui ont arrêté de travailler pour élever
des enfants leur pension de reversions
mastrad 54 % à 75 %
c'est sa justice
mais c'est ça leur famille
et puis je veux aussi que l'on puisse
léguer à ses enfants le fruit de toute
une nuit de travail alors 95 % des
français verront leur impôt sur les
successions supprimer voir leur maison
de famille
nièce c'est sa famille et puis je le dis
je mettrai fin à ce scandale et ses
pannes non contrôlée
certains d'entre nous ont été privés
pendant la crise tout vide d'un droit
inaliénable
celui d'aller voir leurs anciens et bien
moi je vous le dis avec moi ce droit
sera inaliénable crise sanitaire pas
crise sanitaire on pourra toujours avoir
accès à ses aînés et on croit toujours à
les accompagner dans les derniers
moments
et pour ce qui est du monde alors nous
allons encourager nos aînés à rester
chez eux le plus longtemps possible
c'est ce qu'il souhaite et pour cela
nous leur donnerons un crédit d'impôt
pour aménager leur logement et pour
pouvoir avoir auprès de dz à domicile
parce que c'est ça ma conception
aujourd'hui de la vie c'est une
conception dans laquelle les aidants
familiaux ont toute leur place dans
laquelle on leur permet de prendre des
congés pour s'occuper de leur proche en
situation de handicap de leurs proches
malades de leurs proches âgés on leur
permet de prendre un congé parental
jusqu'au 18 ans de l'enfant pourquoi je
vais tout cela est bien parce que la
famille elle aborde quelque chose de
plus que les solidarités collectives
elle aborde quelques chemises
inestimable elle apporte l'affection et
moi je mets aussi dans cette campagne
qu'on parle d'affection et d'amour
alors mes chers amis
aujourd'hui nous avons encore un dernier
problème de la santé et vous le savez
nous vivons avec 5 millions de français
qui n'ont plus de médecin traitant
alors la santé sera nommé grandes
priorités du quinquennat mais je
n'accepte pas que l'on puisse nous dire
aujourd'hui que la santé va bien il va
falloir relever l'hôpital regrette les
25000 personnes il va falloir envoyer
des jeunes étudiants en médecine dans
les territoires carences et moi je vous
le dis avec moi il n'y aura plus de
déserts médicaux en france à la fin du
quinquennat et il n'y aura plus 6000
français en situation de handicap obligé
d'aller se faire accueillir de l'autre
côté de la frontière parce que nous
n'avons pas les structures pour les
accueillir chez nous
alors vous l'avez compris la dignité
seulement au coeur du projet et la
nudité suscité de nombreux territoires
vous venez de la france dévient vous
venez de la france des campagnes je
prends devant vous je redis loria les
paons cela mais j'ai pris au puy en
velay chez une fois leur ont à chaque
fois qu'on investira 1 euro dans les
quartiers prioritaires de la ville on
investira aussi un euro dans la réalité
parce que je veux comme tous les
habitants de france quelle que soit
l'époque sa vie quelle que soit leur
origine quelle que soit la religion est
la même
je veux la vérité
rayonnant ils vendent nous renouerons
avec une grande politique d'aménagement
du territoire nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui de cette grande et belle
ambition pour la france
alors mes amis
je viens je m'ennuie je vous portez un
grand message d'espoir vous savez voilà
pour ce début ce début du dernier
meeting de valérie pécresse elle est à
lyon où elle tient donc c'est son
dernier shooting pour galvaniser une
dernière fois ses troupes cette recette
jours en vo quai aux côtés d'autres
ténors des républicains on l'interrompt
et on va suivre également le début du
meeting du dernier meeting d'eric
zemmour lui l'état à paris au palais des
sports un meeting auprès des jeunes eric
zemmour est en train d'arriver sur scène
de gros moyens là aussi une fois de plus
comme après son ultime de villepin comme
impression meeting du trocadéro - de
sobriété que valérie pécresse on les
écoute un moment si vous voulez
continuer à suivre le discours de
valérie pécresse il est sur la page
d'accueil du figaro.fr vous pouvez le
suivre en intégralité
on écoute et l'examen
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
et
mes chers amis
belle jeunesse française bonsoir à tous
merci merci d'avoir répondu à l'appel et
merci d'être venus aussi nombreux
je salue notre jeunesse je salue
stanislas je salue il est
raisonnable pour les eaux
je salue les
5000 sacs à 1500 6000 qui se sont
mobilisés en 24 heures
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes déjà près de 40 milles sur
youtube je salue
je salue aussi vos aînés qui
m'accompagne qui sont là avec vous ce
soir bonsoir
bonsoir philippe de villiers bonsoir
bonsoir mario mori salle dit en passant
[Applaudissements]
reçu nicolas pêcher en rivière jean
messia et tous les autres
avec vous un b vous nous avons forgé la
plus solide équipe de cette campagne et
je suis fier de vous
quelle joie de vous revoir si nombreux
si enthousiaste si courageux en un
moment capital du destin de notre nation
on dit on dit souvent on dit souvent des
héros c'est un exemple pour notre
jeunesse est bien votre jeunesse est un
exemple pour tous les français
mes amis
mes amis je voudrais commencer ce
meeting par une confidence
gg
c'est une chance immense oui j'ai une
chance immense car depuis le début de
cette campagne depuis les tout premiers
jours de septembre à toulon j'ai à mes
côtés la jeunesse française g
[Applaudissements]
oui
oui vous êtes là et moi aussi je suis là
avec vous
[Musique]
j'ai la chance et j'ai la chance et la
fierté d'avoir vu une jeunesse se lever
à mes côtés
ce sont des veaux oui
souvenez-vous il ya quelques mois la
presse disait de nous mais il n'y a que
des jeunes sherbrooke est
[Musique]
il français
il pensait de critiquer il ne il ne
comprenait pas l'aveu qu'ils faisaient
en écrivant cela
quel merveilleux compliments il nous
faisait oui bien sûr oui évidemment
la jeunesse est chez reconquête
et
vous savez vous savez cette cela
signifie cela signifie que l'avenir est
chez reconquête
êtes
vous êtes jeunes vous êtes intelligent
vous êtes patriote vous êtes à saulon
téméraire kaunas souriant
bref vous êtes français
g
et c'est l'honneur et le privilège
d'être soutenue parce que notre pays
compte plus lucides et de plus énergie
brou
mais
les autres moi aussi je vous ai
mademoiselle
et
les autres candidats pensent les autres
candidats
les
[Applaudissements]
à
c
[Applaudissements]
je je prends le pari que demain dans la
presse on ne me demandera pas mais enfin
ils ont crié vive les femmes vous
condamnez pas sévèrement déficitaire
[Applaudissements]
et
les autres candidats les autres
candidats pensent qu'il suffit de vous
parler de précarité étudiante
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je répète donc les autres candidats
pensent qu'il suffit de vous parler de
précarité étudiante pour vous séduire
[Musique]
ils ne
ils ne comprennent rien ni aux étudiants
ni à la précarité d'ailleurs moi c'est
compris pendant ces quelques mois qu'il
fallait parler à la flamme qui brûle et
en double et
et je sais je sais que partout vous
aller allumer cette flamme non seulement
jusqu'à dimanche mais pour toutes les
années qui viennent
[Applaudissements]
nous avons
nous avons nous avons été la cible des
attaques de tous les vieux partis qui
jalousent votre jeunesse
la cible la cible des médias et du
politiquement correct qui sont eux aussi
civiles
sont eux aussi si vieux et si ringard à
côté de nous
[Applaudissements]
la cible les antifas qui ont été jusqu'à
agresser
ces attaques
ces attaques loin de vous intimider nous
ont renforcés dans votre conviction
mille fois mille fois je me suis dit
quel mouillage quelle force de
conviction vous êtes vous est la figure
de proue de notre mouvement vous êtes la
boussole de la haute conquête vous êtes
l'étoile qui nous faire de repères dans
la nuit politique
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes
interdiction de désespérer vous êtes le
cap que je me fixe parce que vous êtes
la france
victor hugo disait
victor hugo disait je suis une force
qu'il va vous êtes notre force qui va
et
et vous aller toujours plus loin
toujours plus haut vous êtes ceux qui se
rit des sondages et se moque des
statistiques parce que vous savez que
seul front de la ferveur seul importe la
fois
[Applaudissements]
à
vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes
vous êtes la preuve scientifique
qu'impossible n'est pas français
oui
oui merci merci à goutte existait
alors
alors en votre nom à tous
alors on retourne on a tous je veux ce
soir remercier et applaudir génération z
[Applaudissements]
oui quel mouvement quelles organisations
auxquelles travail quelle fougue quelle
énergie en votre nom je veux remercier
ce soir tout particulièrement mon ami
stanislas bigot
[Applaudissements]
incroyable l'incroyable stanislas
l'invincible stanislas
stanislas l'homme qui fait peur à alexis
corbière
stanislas qui pond qui prend chaque jour
le véritable risque pour défendre notre
cause face aux antilles par johann hay
[Applaudissements]
stanislas
la france est fière de toi et comme tous
les militants de génération z se
ressemblent la france est fière de vous
tous
mais
mais je ne suis pas venu seulement
parler aux jeunes de notre mouvement je
suis venu parler à tous les jeunes
français à travers vous ce soir c'est à
eux que je m'adresse le message que je
viens vous transmettre vous allez
pouvoir le leur offrir à votre peut
parler aux jeunes aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas parler un public de plus c'est
parler à l'avenir de la france alors
alors
parce que la france est en danger parce
que nous savons pas ce que le pays que
nous préparons vous y vivrez et vous le
ferez vivre chaque mot compte et toutes
les vérités doivent être dits
oui
vous avez raison d'applaudir parce que à
votre âge à votre âge on veut on exige
la vérité et on se désespère devant les
politiciens et leurs mensonges alors
alors
alors assumons là la vérité tous
ensemble j'ai des choses vitales à vous
dire elle vous concerne tous
personnellement la première vérité que
nous devrons assumer ensemble et que la
france dans laquelle vous vivez est
impitoyable pour les jeunes elle est
impitoyable pour plusieurs raisons
pendant cette campagne on a beaucoup
parlé de la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
des français mais derrière ces mots du
vocabulaire politique
il y à une réalité qui dépasse la
politique une réalité vécue concrètes
qui est le plus souvent dramatiques
parfois même tragique cette réalité
c'est la pauvreté notre pays compte 9
millions de pauvres et ses 9 millions de
trous et parmi ces neuf millions il ya
beaucoup d'étudiants beaucoup trop
d'étudiants ont dit qu'ils sont
précaires mais vous savez aussi bien que
moi mes chers amis quand on révise ses
examens et qu'on a plus les moyens de se
nourrir ni de se chauffer
précarité n'est pas un terme suffisant
c'est plus dur que cela étudié devient
plus difficile on est inquiet on a un
sentiment immense d'injustice
on songe à tout arrêter parce que on ne
voit pas le bout du tunnel à
l'université à l'iut en bts en prépa on
a la tête ailleurs on pense à autre
chose la honte de demander de l'aide à
ses parents par fierté par orgueil parce
qu'on a peur de leur réponse parce que
on culpabilise de leur coûter de
l'argent avec notre choix de suivre des
études et il arrive souvent que nos
parents n'est tout simplement pas les
moyens non plus les moyens de nous aider
je veux parler à sept étudiants dans le
besoin et je veux lui dire non tu n'es
pas seul nous pensons à toi nous te
comprenons
moi aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi aussi j'ai grandi dans un milieu
modeste quand j'ai réussi mes concours
je me souviens je prenais le métro
la ligne 4 je sais pas si vous
connaissez fort depuis hier
et
je
je passais
subrepticement de me quartiers
populaires au quartier latin et à la
station châtelet j'avais l'impression de
franchir le mur de berlin
à l'époque
je révisais sur la table de la cuisine
de ma mère dont le 18e et j'étais en
cours au milieu des bourgeois du 7e
arrondissement
j'ai travaillé dur j'ai commencé au smic
et j'y suis arrivé je comprends
je comprends votre je comprends votre
impatience
j'avais la même pâte et vous
exigez
exigez la prospérité car si vous ne
l'exigé pas dimanche dans l'isoloir elle
ne viendra jamais les autres vous disent
que rien n'est possible moi je vous dis
impossible n'est pas français
et
[Applaudissements]
et je veux je veux faire signe de très
loin mais de très près dans mon coeur
aux jeunes français des territoires et
départements de première
bien souvent bien souvent ils sont
encore plus le délai c'est que les
jeunes de métropole trop souvent ils
sont encore plus d'éclat c'est que les
jeunes de nos campagnes bien souvent ils
se demandent si paris pense encore à
avec vous ici je veux leur dire ce soir
oui ici à paris du pensons à bout de
photos sur nous nous avons confiance
car
car dimanche il n'y aura qu'une seule
force
[Musique]
merci au beausset
car dimanche dimanche il n'y aura qu'une
seule france une seule nation un seul
pop nous serons avec nous soyez avec
nous
[Applaudissements]
est cher
mais chers amis je veux vous demander
aussi ce soir l'exigé toute votre vie le
respect de votre identité le respect de
votre pays et la protection de votre
sécurité vous avez
vous avez le devoir vous avez le devoir
d'exiger la sécurité pour vos parents et
pour vous même car la france la france
vous vivez vous jeunes français est
impitoyable pour vous vous êtes les
premières victimes de l'insécurité les
racailles les racailles vous attaque
parce que
[Applaudissements]
les racailles vous attaque parce que
vous êtes honnête et que votre honnêteté
les dérange il voudrait que vous soyez
comme que vous ne respectiez rien alors
il vous respecterai mes vous respectez
votre pays vous respecter la loi
respecter l'école et le savoir vivre
pour respecter vos parents votre culture
et votre mode de vie et cela se voit
cela les rend fous deraedt et xo
je je me souviens d'arthur
un étudiant grenoblois que j'ai
rencontrés au début de l'année il me
racontait que presque tous les jours ils
se faisaient agresser sur le chemin de
l'université
agressé pour rien même pas même pas
même pas pour lui voler son téléphone
son argent c'est encore pire cela
s'appelle de la pure violence gratuite
de la pure haine de la plus rennes et
osons dire et osons le dire
du pur racisme anti blanc
cela
solar
cela me révolte vous en souffrez et j'en
souffre avec vous
chaque jour
[Applaudissements]
chaque jour notre pays chaque jour notre
pays connaît ce genre de tragédies
1800 agressions par jour dans notre pays
à la fin à la fin de ce multi à la fin
le sol eating plus de 200 porcs français
innocents se seront fait agresser
[Musique]
chacune chacun
chacune de ces agressions
chacune de ces agressions doit nous
révolter
[Musique]
chacune de ces agressions dois me
révolter nous ne pouvons pas nous dire
comme certains l'ont dit cette semaine
que des drames comme ceux-là sont
banales nous ne pouvons plus
nous ne pouvons plus les cacher nous
devons en parler nous n'acceptons plus
l'omerta
récemment récemment de ces agressions a
tourné à la tragédie
elle tournera peut-être demain au
scandale d'état je crois je crois que
vous savez que je veux en effet vous
parlez
je crois que vous savez que je veux vous
parler de jérémy cohen mes chers amis
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis
à la mémoire de ce jeune homme handicapé
tabasser lynché par des barbares à
bobigny à la mémoire de jérémy qui s'est
levé
ensanglanté qui a tenté de s'échapper et
qui ont s'échapperont cp percutées par
un tramway à la mémoire de cet enfant
innocente à la mémoire de votre frère je
vous demande s'il vous plaît de vous
lever et de respecter une minute
merci le cher ami
je veux
je veux que vous sachiez que cette
histoire me bouleverse elle me
bouleverse parce que jérémy aurait pu
être mon fils elle me bouleverse parce
que tout a été fait pour que le scandale
n'explose pas parce que une manipulation
politique s'est enclenchée pour que
personne n'en parle cette tragédie me
bouleverse parce que la famille a dû se
battre pour enquêter elle même parce
qu'elle a dû m'écrire pour me demander
d'en parler pour que la sphère 3 enfin
le jour
je n'ai pas
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr je n'ai pas toutes les réponses
mais je me pose beaucoup de questions
pourquoi une tragédie survenue le 16
février dernier ne ressort telles que le
4 ap parce que je perde which pourquoi
une famille doit elle mène l enquête
seuls pourquoi cette omerta sur un fait
survenu à 20 heures c'est à dire l'heure
de pointe avec des dizaines de témoins
autour de la cèze pourquoi la presse
titre tel accident de tramway au sujet
de la mort de jérémy
j'espère
j'espère j'espère que dans les jours qui
viennent nous aurons enfin des réponses
depuis que j'ai parlé de la tragédie de
jérémy je reçois des dizaines de
messages de familles de victimes qui
maudissent leur révolte devant
l'attitude de l'état devant les
criminels parfois encore en liberté
devant l' omerta suivante sachez que je
me bats pour vous
la deuxième vérité la deuxième vérité
que je veux dire à la jeunesse française
c'est que la france dans laquelle
vivaient porte atteinte à votre liberté
tout le système politique et médiatique
vous demande de vous auto censure et de
baisser les yeux et de baisser les bras
pendant de longues années pendant de
longues années la macro ni vous à
masquer nous a condamnés au couvre-feu
d'un condamné ou pas sanitaires eau pour
un distance
télétravail à la visioconférence
ban dans chaque jeune il y a une volonté
de liberté il ya une révolte et jamais
la liberté et la révolte des jeunes
meute était aussi quadrillé ci ont
veillé mu n'est que sous le règne des
manuels d'accueil
vous êtes vous êtes ceux qui ont le plus
souffert de la politique sanitaire le
plus souvent de manière injuste et
cruelle et le pouvoir a méprisé votre
centre ans je sais je sais que vous lui
en voulez et vous avez raison de lui en
vouloir et quand on sait en plus que
tout cette stratégie de la peur a été
conçu par mckinsey qui avaient déjà
contribué
y avait des gens qui avaient déjà
contribué gratuitement à la compagne
d'emmanuelle macro
[Applaudissements]
quand on sait quand on sait que cette
campagne a été conçue par mckinsey qui
avait travaillé gratuitement pour
emmanuel macron et qu' ils ont et qu'ils
ont vu des données sur nos vies
personnelles et sur notre état alors
qu'il s'agit d'une société américaine
quand on sait qu'ils n'ont pas payé
d'impôt rend plus on ne peut on ne peut
que porter un regard sévère très sévère
sur la manière dont vous avez été
traités alors je veux féliciter ici les
parlementaires de reconquête pour leur
saisine du parquet national
je
je suis fier que reconquête soit
toujours pionnier dans la recherche de
la vérité la troisième vérité que je
veux vous dire ce soir et que le système
éducatif français n'est pas construit
pour vous mais pour servir des
idéologies qui déconstruisent notre
jeunesse
après
après tout ce que l'éducation nationale
nous a fait subir c'est un miracle que
vous soyez là honneur à vous
oui
à
oui vous êtes là et on ne te ra vous car
vous avez résisté à la doxa vous avez
résisté à la propagande et oui vous êtes
là je suis très sincère je me demande
souvent comment vous avez fait pour
échapper à cet endoctrinement
[Applaudissements]
merci vous ne pouviez pas me faire plus
beau compliment
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je veux rendre hommage à votre
pense de conviction à votre esprit
critique nous avons besoin d'écoles de
lycées universités qui vous fasse aimer
la france et vous prêt à partir à la
conquête de kobe
aujourd'hui
les enfants les adolescents les jeunes
françaises n'apprennent plus qu à
détester leurs pays et à déconstruire
leur civilisation
dans une absence de discipline qui
confine au chaos et une absence
d'exigence qui mène tout droit au
déclassement
vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas d'accord
et c'est tout à votre honneur je ne suis
pas d'accord non plus et vous défendre
et ma mission tout mon programme répond
à cette exigence
la quatrième vérité que je veux vous
livrer ce soir et que l'écologie dont
vous parle les politiciens n'est pas
l'écologie les éoliennes
ce n'est pas l'écologie
greta tomber yannick jadot emmanuel
match ce n'est pas
des 300 ce qui est le masque de la
misère ce n'est pas l'écologie
l'interdiction
l'interdiction de l'élevage des
traditions de la chasse ce n'est pas
l'écologie
tout cela pour cela c'est c'est
l'idéologie la langue de bois et le
politiquement correct ça n'a rien à voir
avec la nature ni avec la vie la vraie
écologie est française elle est dans la
beauté de nos paysages et de nos
villages elle est dans notre ve ou
modérée pour les bonnes choses
elle est
allée dans les circuits courts qui
permettent aux producteurs et aux
consommateurs de vivre mieux elle est
dans le respect de nos savoir faire de
nos artisanat de nos modes de vie elle
est dans le respect pour l'environnement
parce qu'il est notre environnement
notre héritage notre fierté et notre
richesse
elle est
elle est dans la revitalisation de notre
monde rural qui a été honteusement
abandonné par paris au profit des
banlieues la vérité
la véritable écologie est dans nos
coeurs et dans nos âmes elle et elle est
aussi dans le nucléaire l'énergie la
moins polluante au monde est la seule à
pouvoir garantir notre souveraineté
énergétique
la véritable écologie c'est nous et nous
sommes mille fois plus écologiste que
les prétendus écologistes
vous avez raison d'aimer la nature et
vous avez raison de rejeter la fausse
écologie
voilà
voilà les vérités que personne d'autre
que moi ne voit là les vérités que vous
allez pouvoir offrir à tous ceux qui
croiseraient dans les trois jours qui
viennent alors maintenant à trois jours
du premier tour il est temps que nous
armer de sévérité nous disions quelle
france nous voulons qu'elle france nous
proposons aux français quelle france
nous allons forget quel france vous
méritez et parce que vous la méritez
quelle france vous avez le droit
d'exiger d'exiger avec force jusqu'à
l'obtenir quelle france est au bout de
notre victoire
oui
à
[Applaudissements]
oui
vous avez le droit d'exiger une france
en paix nos adversaires nous disent que
nous sommes trop ferme dans nos propos
mais nous sommes parce que la paix ne
tombe pas comme un fruit mûr la paix il
faut la vouloir il faut la gagner il
faut l'arracher à la fatalité qui la
détruit il faut l'aimer par dessus tout
je tiens un langage ferme parce qu'il
faut être ferme pour avoir la paix
regardez l'emblème de notre campagne
c'est une branche d'olivier l'arbre qui
symbolise la paix la paix est la chose
la plus sérieuse au monde
la paix
et lâche
la paix est la chose la plus sérieuse au
monde et il faut la concevoir la
construire la faire grandir et la
renforcer sans cesse le but le but de la
reconquête 'cela fait l'objectif de
notre combat c'est la paix nous aurons
gagné pour la france sera enfin fait
alors
alors à quoi ressemblera cette france je
vais où la dcri voilà la france de
demain la france reconquise si l'on peut
dire là notre labo cette france est un
pays sans lutte des classes sans lui
terrasse sans lutte des sexes sans
guerres de religion ni guerre civile
sow
[Musique]
sans lutte des classes d'abord car nous
allons réconcilier les riches et les
pauvres les entrepreneurs et les
salariés les patrons et le pop
depuis
depuis un siècle depuis un siècle la
gauche demande aux plus démunis de
détester les plus aisés je mettrai fin à
cet esprit de vengeance notre france ne
sera ni la force ni la france d'être au
mais il faut tout chacun y compris les
plus pauvres aura le droit de s'enrichir
une france qui donnera envie de
s'enrichir et qui donnera le droit de
s'enrichir jean luc mélenchon
disait récemment que
il disait récemment que vouloir devenir
milliardaire est une ambition immoral
quelle quelle aberration mes amis il
méprise il méprise les innombrables
français nés dans des milieux très
modestes et qui à force de travail
acharné d'ingéniosité d'audace ont fini
chef d'entreprise ou capitaines
d'industrie
jeu
de poney
je connais un homme qui a invité toute
son enfance dans une chambre de bonne à
vexer peindre ses parents avaient tout
juste de quoi le nourrir aujourd'hui il
dirige une immense entreprise
technologique et il a des milliers de
salariés il a voulu il a voulu réussir
au plus haut point en partant de presque
rien non non son ambition n'était pas
immoral aujourd'hui il crée des emplois
il crée de la richesse il participe au
succès de notre nation sur le marché
mondial simplement
hélas dans la france d'aujourd'hui son
destin est une exception je veux qu'il
devienne un exemple je veux qu'il y ait
bientôt cent mille dix mille français
comme lui je veux la contagion de la
prospérité
je veux
je veux là je veux la multiplication des
grandes aventures je veux une france où
la richesse ne soit plus jamais
considéré comme une faute je veux que
vous n'ayez pas honte est ambitieux je
veux une france où le succès soit le
maître étalon de l'action je ne veux pas
une france qui se contente de respecter
le travail je veux une france m le
travail je veux
je veux une france qui osent se classer
pour objectif non seulement la sortie de
crise non seulement le pouvoir d'achat
non seulement la croissance mais la
prospérité oui la prospérité la
prospérité pour vous pour votre famille
c'est bien plus beau que le pouvoir
d'achat je veux la réussite je veux
l'ambition parce que nous y avons droit
parce que notre histoire nous dit que
nous en sommes capables parce que nous
ne voulons pas d'une faute de mieux et
du mieux que rien je suis le seul
candidat qui promettent la prospérité et
j'en suis tellement fier
voilà
voilà ce qu'est un pays sortie des
classes nous mettrons également fin à la
lune et race le peuple
le
le peuple français ne supportent plus
que l'étiquette de raciste soit collée
par les médias et les anti-pacs surtout
et de droite
[Musique]
ce terrorisme intellectuel a paralysé le
débat politique trop longtemps et notre
démocratie tout entier je vais vous
raconter une histoire qui m'a marqué un
jour j'aidais ma fille perd ici pour un
de ses cours d'histoire je parle pendant
quelques minutes elle m'arrête et me dit
non non je ne te demande pas la vérité
je te demande seulement ce qu'il faut
dit
ce qu'ils font est ce que vous vous
rendez compte j'ai compris ce jour là
que
j'ai compris j'ai compris ce jour là que
nous vivions désormais dont l'urss vous
avez tous intériorisé à votre âge qu'il
y avait d'un côté la vérité et de
l'autre le discours officiel celui qu'on
a le droit d'exprimer
de la sapn la terreur
la poste jeu de la france que je veux
sera un pays réconcilié
vous aurez le droit de penser ce que
vous voudrez ont pour écrire ce que vous
voudrez dans vos copies et dire ce que
vous voudrez l'ordre sauront sans avoir
peur depuis
oui
sans avoir peur d'être puni aux opinions
je veux un pays où l'on a droit de
s'opposer sans être censuré où la
liberté d'expression est un bien
précieux ou la défense de la patrie
n'est pas jugé comme un crime ce qui
nous accuse de diviser de fractures et
de cliver comme ils disent sont
justement ceux qui veulent diviser la
france en deux camps les politiquement
correct qui ont tous les droits y
compris celui de me traiter d'antisémite
quelle absurdité au passage
[Applaudissements]
d'un côté donc cela qu'ils ont tous les
droits et les patriotes qui n'ont que le
droit de se taire nous ne nous tairons
plus est la france retrouvera sa
légendaire franchise son insolence sa
vitalité cette discussion perpétuelle
qui fait le sel le plaisir la richesse
de notre vie publique où aucune opinion
n'est justiciable
oui mes amis
[Musique]
vous êtes ronde nous cesserons d'être la
france des antilles fin et nous
redeviendrons la france de victory cause
je veux
je veux un pays sont lutte des sexes
également non l'homme n'est pas
l'ennemie de la femme on la femme n'est
pas l'ennemi de l'homme
et
et je veux et je veux m'adresser ce soir
à toutes les jeunes femmes qui sont là
vous avez été magnifique pendant sept
ans
vous m'avez
m'avait aidé tout au long de l'année
grâce soit rendue
grasse ne soit rendu alors que me vaut
d'être si détestée par les féministes il
n'y a au fond si l'on réfléchit bien une
seule raison
[Musique]
c'est que nous n'avons pas la même
définition de du féminisme si le
féminisme c'est vouloir l'égalité de
droits entre les hommes et les pas
malheureux je suis féministe autant
ministre et toutes les femmes sont
ministre bay
mais
si
mais si le féminisme c'est prôner la
différenciation sexuelle
si le féminisme s'est opposé des hommes
aux femmes et les hommes ou femmes 6
si c'est croire que les deux sont dans
une guerre permanente alors je ne veux
pas de ce néo féminisme là
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
et il me semble que la plupart des
femmes n'en veulent pas non plus
non non la majorité des femmes
françaises ne veut pas abolir toutes les
différences qu'elles ont avec les hommes
elles veulent elles veulent être libres
d'être féminine ou pas libre d'avoir les
cheveux longs pas libres d'être mère pas
libre de faire ce qu'elles veulent la
majorité
joe rites et des femmes
[Applaudissements]
la majorité des femmes françaises ne
veut pas de cette lutte des sexes ce
prolongement cette substitution à la
lutte des classes jusque dans la vie
privée et jusque dans la vie intime les
femmes françaises aiment leurs pères
leurs maris leurs fils pour la grande
majorité des femmes françaises non les
hommes ne sont pas des ennemis les
femmes françaises aiment la complicité
entre les hommes et femmes elle aime les
gens
elle
elle sème les hommes qui les respecte et
elle respecte les hommes qui les aiment
alors
dans ma france les femmes auront la
liberté elles auront la sécurité et
elles verront tous leurs droits
respectés cheveux
je veux
un pays sans guerres de religion
évidemment car sur le sol
car
sur le sol français
aujourd'hui la seule guerre de religion
c'est le diable
nous allons le chasser hors de nos
frontières
manu militari
[Applaudissements]
alors alors les musulmans qui aiment la
france vivront en paix chez nous et nous
vivront en paix avec nous
et enfin
et enfin surtout je veux un pays sans
guerre civile nous serons donc dès les
premières semaines de mon mandat est un
rassemblement pendant cinq ans
impitoyable à l'égard des barbares des
délinquants des criminels des matca qui
ont fait de la france leur terrain
nous leur ferons nous leur ferons pas
c'est le bout d'agresser nos femmes nos
enfants nos personnes âgées nos villes
et nos villages notre économie et nos
lois ils ne sauront pas
ils ne seront pas seulement combattu ils
seront vaincus nous non
[Applaudissements]
nous n'aurons plus peur d'eux et la peur
changera en fin de compte
alors
alors à toutes ces conditions car toutes
sont indispensables nous jouirons enfin
de ce que nous espérons depuis si
longtemps ce que nous méritons depuis
toujours et donc les politiciens et les
hors la loi nous ont privé la paix la
paix
la paire
la paix chez nous la paix pour nous la
paix grâce à de l'appétit dans la
sécurité dans la liberté et dans la
prospérité la paix qui est dans nos
coeurs et qui règnera enfin dans notre
pays la france que nous préparons
la france que nous préparons sera aussi
douce de puissants aussi tolérante
coordonnées aussi joyeuse que sérieuse
aussi belle que forte aussi séduisante
que tu meurs
elle elle sera la france dont les
générations futures diront ils ont fait
un pays ils ont fait un pays où il fait
bon vivre un pays où nous n'avons plus
peur à pays où nous serons heureux de
faire des enfants de les envoyer à
l'école ils ont fait un pays où les
enfants savent parfaitement lire écrire
compter où ils apprennent être ambitieux
travailleurs créatif respectueux
française
il
ils ont fait un pays où la campagne les
plus méprisés par l'habile ils ont fait
un pays où la bureaucratie n'écrase plus
les travailleurs ils ont fait un pays le
pouvoir d'achat est supérieur aux taxes
et aux impôts
ils ont fait un pays on a le droit de
s'enrichir
ils ont fait à payer ou les traditions
sont respectées
ils ont fait un pays où la santé la
propriété et la liberté sont sacrés ils
ont fait un pays qui ne craint rien ni
personne ils ont fait le pays qui leur
ressemble
on nous admirera et on aura raison
alors
alors vous voyez à quel point le jeu en
vaut la chandelle la bataille n'est pas
terminée
il nous reste trois jours
un tiers des français ne sais toujours
pas pour qui il va voter dimanche
et
et millions de nos compatriotes se
décideront au dernier moment dans
l'isoloir alors alors trois jours c'est
long comme une éternité ne lâchez rien
soyez combatifs parler beaucoup aidé en
métaux
novak et tout ce qui passe à votre
reporter famille amis collègues
passons postiers commerçants policiers
soyez radieux soyez baba soyez bourgis
ans chaque ligne chaque track chaque
message sur les réseaux sociaux sur tous
les forums dans tous les enfants dans
toutes les salles de sport tous les
métros et tous les bus tous qu'on vous
conter je compte sur vous autant que
vous pouvez compter sur moi jeunesse
possède la profession
soumettra la lutte des classes ni à la
lutte des races ni au jihad né à la
guerre civile rien ni personne ne nous
privera de notre tranquillité lieu de la
douceur de l'existence ni de notre
tendresse pour nous mêmes rien ni
personne ne nous privera de la paix
parce qu'il faudrait nous arracher le
coeur et
que la jeunesse la plus mobilisée de
france
parce que la france a concilié prospère
nation qui fait protéger ses enfants et
ses frères
et qui ne baissera jamais les yeux
de l'effort et de la récré pause
l avenir
[Musique]
ok
mais il le fait vive la fraternité
vive le réputé public
à
[Applaudissements]
voilà pour ce meeting eric zemmour on
palais des sports de paris on a suivi
toute la soirée ensemble les derniers
grands meetings dernière ligne droite
avant la présidentielle plus que trois
jours marine le pen était tout à l'heure
à perpignan valérie pécresse était à
lyon eric zemmour ce soir dans ce
dernier grand meeting avec les jeunes
étaient à paris merci de nous avoir
suivi sur sur le figaro live je remercie
benjamin délit qui est elle arrivée là
réalisation ce soir la politique ça
continue avec nous avec cette grande
soirée dimanche soir évidemment tous les
résultats à 20h on sera partout dans
tous les qg vous donnera aussi les
résultats dans vos communes si vous vous
demandez quel est le score dans chacune
de vos villes et villages n'hésitez pas
nous suivre encore on se retrouve très
vite sur le figaro live merci
[Musique]